uh thank you members
uh good evening members officers members
of the public can I welcome you to this
planning committee meeting on when see
the 14th of December
as usual I have to go through
housekeeping for those who haven't been
along uh to sit with us before if the
fire alarm is activated can you please
keep the offices via the stairs which
are opposite the lifts
and also you can use the door to my
right which will lead you stairs
downstairs
assemble on holy green holy Square green
and if it's safe to do so the officers
will bring you back over here so we can
continue the meeting
uh does anybody attend filming this
meeting this evening
no thank you I will remind members and
the public that that we are being live
streamed on the council's YouTube
channel
restriction of mobile phones with
everybody present please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent and
they are not used to make and receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst this
meet is in progress
members requesting to speak under
Council procedure
20.1 I have one here at the moment which
is councilor Bailey and I believe the
item is 4L comes to Bailey York Street
councilor 4L yes Yorkshire York Street
my trip sorry is it
York Street yeah sorry sorry councilor
you hear what you're saying it's the
voice again as usual thank you are there
any uh other members
who aren't on the committee wish to
speak tonight
I can't see anything Q
uh public speaking I have public
speaking on agenda items
for a All Saints industrial estate in
Margate items 4B Land South of
Millennium Way process item four C St
Mary's Avenue Margate
item four D 31 Southward Road Ramsgate
item four the Outlook Foxboro Lane
Minster and item 4L for York Street
process with members please note
agenda item one I have apologies and
received from councilor shrub
counselor Rollins is substitute I also
have apologies from councilor Everett
I'm not sure whether
counselor if it has a thank you
councilman
are there any other apologies
no I can't see any thank you agenda item
two uh Declarations of Interest
thank you pronounce Wing yes chair item
40 which is 53 Addington Street my
revised planning application
thank you that that is noted thank you
very much
uh gender item three do members agree
that the minutes of the planning
committee meeting held on the 16th of
November
2022 be approved as a correct record
could I have a proposer please councilor
Auburn seconder councilman Coleman cook
do members agree
thank you members
agenda item four schedule of planning
applications
any site visits members and it will be
warmer in January will take place on the
so they tell me we'll be on the 6th of
January which is a Friday
in 2023
just going to hand over to
Mr Livingston our planning applications
manager for a point of information
thank you chair point of information for
members on schedule item 4E 53 Addington
Street Ramsgate the report contains a
summary of a representation received
which includes defamatory accusations
towards the applicant this
representation was not published online
however the comments were included in
the committee report in error on behalf
of the planning department I wish to
sincerely apologize the applicant
councilor wing for this error and these
comments should be disregarded by
members in determining the planning
application thank you chair
thank you Ian and supported that and
apologies as well from myself as a chair
uh agenda item 4A or Saints industrial
estate or Saints Avenue in Margate
speaking against its application is Mr
hogman is Mr hogman here
Hodgman a big apartment Mr hochman you
have three minutes to make your comments
please
okay good evening
um the the developer poses to build 50a
industrial units
on the site
which is quite a big site and quite a
lot of units
um
they've had a
they intend to build over a lot of the
access roads
on the estate which will cause serious
problems to the people already on the
estate there are
um a couple of firms already on this
state that use
articulated lorries
and they state in their transport
assessments
that the biggest
vehicle expected to arrive on the estate
is a dust card
um if an articulated
vehicle comes on the estate
once it's built the only way to be able
to get off will be by reversing out the
estate there is no way it will turn
around because they intend to build
these uh units on a lot of the roadways
and the access ways that is wrong and
that will cause problems you cannot
reverse an articulated vehicle
back out into the road is dangerous
um the the dust carts they're referring
to they're saying uh about 39 foot long
an articulated vehicle is 55 foot long
with a gross vehicle weight of 44 tons
there's a company on the estate called
can do timber they have regular
deliveries made by these vehicles
several times a week if these vehicles
can't turn around on your state they can
at the moment but once they're the
buildings are put up they will not be
able to turn around
this is just unacceptable it will be
dangerous no one's taking that into
account
with this application that needs
addressing
also if you look at the the plans
they've submitted for the new buildings
they've put a new roadway I don't know
if you've got the information in front
of you a new road going up the side of
the existing uh old building the old
good good shade and then they've got
roads going off to the right where the
new warehousing is okay which is fine
but as you drive down there towards the
end it just comes to a stop it's just a
brick wall at the end there's no way of
of sort of you can't turn out it's a
cul-de-sac now if you even if you get a
bin Lorry going around there and all
these all these new units will have to
have bins you've got to get rid of the
waste it'll be commercial it won't be
the council it'll be commercial waste
contractor doing it they'll have to go
around and pick these bins out and enter
the bins when they come to the end of
that little road they'll have no way of
turning around they'll have to reverse
back out onto the other Road and do the
same thing again it's ridiculous there's
no room for large vehicles to turn
around once they've gone down in into
where the new the new builds are that's
just not acceptable
that will cause problems and that should
be addressed and they say also in their
report that they don't expect any
large articulated 16.5 meter articulated
vehicles to visit these new
um buildings when they're put up these
new warehouses that's nonsense that's
absolute nonsense these people are going
to be renting these new units they've
got big roller shots of doors they're
renting them so they can get big things
in the building like pallets and stuff
like that these are going to come down
on lorries some of them will be
articulated vehicles if you don't
believe me go over to manston to the new
estate that's been built over there
they've got similar size industrial
units there
and they're having large vehicles in
there every day you know to say actually
on this statement that we don't expect
any vehicle larger than the dust guard
to visit the estate at any time he's
absolute nonsense and this should not be
allowed to go ahead
that's it
uh thank you very much I've let you go
over time there because our lovely
antique roadshow is it functioning now
Stephen right which keep an eye on the
BBC uh Bargain Hunt
right okay thank you I'll watch you uh
thank you for that um also speaking
against this application is a Mis gauge
and I hope I pronounce that right
thank you all right thank you good
evening
um thank you for having me to speak at
this evening's meeting my name is Hannah
gagan and I live on Railway Terrace the
nearest residential street to this
proposed development this row of houses
has been there for over 100 years and
over time has been boxed in on all sides
by privately owned land
our only access is from a set of steps
on All Saints Avenue next to the
entrance the industrial States leading
to the rear of our houses
we don't have any bin Collections and
currently there would be no access for
emergency vehicles in the event of a
fire whilst our welcome sensible
development of the Wasteland beyond my
front garden I have concerns about this
proposal and the impact it will have on
me my neighbors and the environment
I'm certainly not against any
development of this land I would much
prefer for it to be in use in the
current Wasteland which has resulted in
fires and anti-social behavior in recent
years
but I would like the thoughts and the
concerns of Railway Terrace residents be
taken into consideration before any
major Works May begin
our main concern is emergency egress in
the event of a fire with only one way
out we feel dangerously trapped if the
development didn't provide any emergency
exit from the front of our properties we
feel this would present a risk for the
residents of the 13 houses we've had
visits from local fire offices over the
years who agreed that the current single
exit route is insufficient and unsafe
when emergency Gas Works required early
this year a metal fence had to be cut
away to allow access to the workers once
again highlighting how trapped we are
getting access via Tivoli Park Avenue is
not possible so our only option for
another safe route two from our house
would be via the area covered in this
application
it's if this development goes ahead it
would be vital for permanent access to
the front of our property be included
both the safety and convenience of
residents the row of trees where our
properties boarded industrial estate are
very important they act as a shield to
noise and light for the industrial State
Railway line and Dreamland and Beyond it
any development must keep these in place
to fully support or suppose application
I need to have a much clearer idea of
the planned use of these new buildings
and what they would be included the
proposed hours of operation many Railway
terrorist residents have children or
work from home we have bedrooms and
lounges facing the site any potential
noise pollution from industrial units
would impact our quality of life heavily
the extra traffic that this development
would attract both during the
construction ongoing use of the site
would also have a large impact on local
residents it's an already busy area and
dangerous corner for cars and
pedestrians alike with heavy Goods
Vehicles regularly visiting the
industrial units any extra traffic not
to mention influx during the high
tourism summer months and the pollution
that this extra traffic brings would
have an impact on people living in all
nearby streets if this application is
granted we would ask the relatives to be
good neighbors involved local residents
and consultations going forward we would
welcome a conversation about the
inclusion of parking spaces Railway
Terrace residents and enabling bin and
recycling collections thank you
uh thank you very much I now ask the
planning officer which is Ian to outline
this application thank you
thank you chair
so the application is an outline
application for the erection of 58 light
industrial units which is use class uh
EG
with parking so it's now an application
but the only matter that is reserved is
is Landscaping so sort of hard and soft
surfaces across the development so
appearance scale access uh you know and
design is all is all for consideration
so the size outlined in red you can see
as mentioned Railway Terrace is the sort
of semi-circle of properties as
mentioned access via a staircase which
you can just see on off the where the
mouse is here you've then got properties
on on Tivoli Park Avenue which runs down
on one boundary of the site and then
you've got our other collection of
industrial units which makes up the All
Saints industrial estate
so the site is allocated under policy
e01 of the local plan which supports
light industrial uses where it would not
harm the living conditions of
Residential Properties in close
proximity so the principle of
development is acceptable however it
falls for members to consider the impact
on matters such as character appearance
of the area living conditions of
residents highways environments and Etc
so this is an aerial image of the site
so you can see that there is a large
area of hard surfacing which is
currently sort of undeveloped in terms
of no structures on it at the moment
there's some various things that are on
the site which we'll look at when we're
looking at the images
so just to go in with a 3D view so it's
an isometric view you can see on the
left hand side of the image again top
top left hand side of the image you can
see Railway Terrace then Tivoli Park
Avenue properties you can see the bank
of trees that's been mentioned which
we'll look at in a bit more detail when
we're on ground level and then you can
see the um the good sheds of Stage
Station shed that is on the on the site
adjacent to the red line as well as some
of the other businesses that are
operating at the rear of the site some
of which have access which relates to
this proposal and others of which have
access via the the section of the land
that's the the top of the image
obviously you can see the railway at the
top there as well
so this is the existing access into the
site
um some members may be familiar with
this you can see on the right hand side
the the trees that start to run around
the site and the embankment which is
part of this site
um this is then looking back towards
that access so it's not quite a uh well
it's not a double width for vehicles at
the moment
uh then this is another 3D view so this
is a view that shows um the access that
we were just looking at at the top right
of the image and you can see Railway
Terrace is in front of us if you see the
mouse going around here and with those
trees so it's showing at the moment
you've got a hoarding that's erected
around this site which forms the
application site which we'll look at now
so going down then so we're continuing
through the axis we're just going to go
around the corner here where you can see
it in the fog a car on the left hand
side there which is where the hoarding
starts but you can see the corner of
property on Railway Terrace so you can
see the changing land level that occurs
between this site and the properties on
on Railway Terrace
and then that's a view towards the back
of that property so that cloud property
was the one we saw in the in the Mr a
second ago and you can see that again
the change in level and the embankment
and the start of the trees and you can
see on the left hand side the start of
the hoarding
so then this is a view further back you
can see the start the rest of the
hoarding and back where the existing
access into the industrial estate is
and then this is a further wider view
showing that hoarding at the moment and
those that bank of trees in the
background
so this is now within the site so the
hoarding you can see the back of is on
the right hand side of the image and
that's the trees that run around that
semi-circle of Railway Terrace
and then going into a bit more detail
looking on the left hand side of this
image
there we go
um you can see the other end of Railway
Terrace railroad Terrace has got two
sets of properties and this is the other
end property there so again this is just
to show the detail of the change in
level and also that that bank of trees
that's present as well
so in looking at the properties on
Tivoli Park Avenue so this is another 3D
image showing the site and the back of
those properties there so you can see
again that bank of trees so we're just
going to go through some images looking
at those so starting on the right hand
side of this image here so around where
the mouse is on the right hand side
looking again at that bank of trees and
you can just about make out the tops of
some roofs of properties uh above those
uh the existing fence at the top of the
bank
then this is a view just looking back
again you can see Arlington in the
background and that hoarding running
along there so you can see on the left
hand side those trees at the back of
Toby Park Avenue
this is again A View round showing those
trees at the moment you can see
obviously the site is partially uh
developed so it's previously developed
land with the hard surfacing that's
there
turns the left from that image you can
see again the backs of those properties
so you can see the dorm window at a roof
level
and you can see that these these windows
are all at first floor level on the
properties on Tiffany Park Avenue again
you can see that changing level
and then again going to the left of this
image
you can then see uh you've got some some
stuff that's being stored on site at the
moment and then if I go the next one
again just to show that 3D image so that
that um uh effectively back of a truck
that we had uh or or container unit
um is in this area here so you can see
that relationship again and then you've
got the area of the site which is a
separate use not part of the application
site at the rear
turning around then just looking at the
other end of the other side of the site
you can see the collection of different
industrial uses that are that are
present
and looking at what that looks like from
the ground you can see it's sort of
elevated
um it's a two-story in height but single
story uh with a with a large pitch roof
and then this is right at the back of
the site so this is where the access
runs to that runs along
so if I go back that runs all the way
along this building and you can see just
in this corner here
um a series of properties which are then
present you can see here so you can see
there's an access all the way through to
the back of the site
so there is a previous approval on this
um site in particular so there was an
application in 2016 for the erection of
three industrial units
um the image on the left hand side that
Shades these units red and blue the red
shows um what would be B1 and B8 uses so
in the old use classes order that was
light industrial and storage and
distribution uses
with the blue half of the building to be
I think it's B1 and B2 uses B2 is
General industrial so they are the the
noisier potentially smellier uses which
obviously require quite a lot of
controls if they're anywhere near
Residential Properties so that
application was approved by Committee in
2016 under pretty much the same policy
that we've got now in the new local plan
which is about retention of employment
sites which supported these uses
um
so that permission is not extant it
wasn't implemented so it's granted but
wasn't implemented
so the proposal itself as mentioned it's
for 58 light industrial units
as a sort of headline summary they're
proposing to keep all the trees that are
around the site you can see it shown on
this this site plan it provides for two
spaces two vehicle spaces per unit with
visitor spaces provided as well to
provide in total
138 parking spaces
um
just to show you again in terms of the
neighboring properties just so members
can can get the idea
um you've obviously got that raised
section again that semi-circle Ray
section and then the gap between Tivoli
Park Avenue properties and the trees
before you then get to the site and the
units
so looking at in a bit more detail I'm
going to just go through the three site
plans that make up the hole and then
we'll just look at the elevations in a
bit more detail so this is the front of
the site where they are proposing to add
so remove some of the the embankment on
the left-hand side of the access as you
go in to create some additional parking
spaces you've also got a pedestrian
Footwear that's being Incorporated
either side and obviously down one side
as well the areas in yellow are areas
that are indicated to be open space as
mentioned the detail of that Landscaping
will be part of any reserve matters if
permission is granted this triangle
section of land here
was previously proposed within this
application to have a cafe on it however
that was removed from The Proposal the
urging of officers given the allocation
of the site for the particular
particular use that area has now got um
obviously we've got these two parking
spaces here
um so and then you've got the the start
of the units
um obviously in this this section of the
site in the lower part of the image then
moving through in just a bit more detail
you've got
um this showing the layout of those
units with the the road as mentioned by
the representation on the right hand
side of the image with the access in
with the different units fronting onto
those roads you've then got
um all the trees on the left-hand side
of the image and the embankment you can
see a retaining wall That's proposed to
run around that embankment
uh which is indicated by the the double
thickness line
and then looking down at the
um southern part of the site
just see the rest of the layout you can
see that access point on the the right
hand side of the image there which ran
to that um the yard that you could see
where you could see the houses behind in
the in the photo
so just to look in a bit more detail at
the design of the units themselves so
taking the top of the site and looking
at these units here
uh this is the set of units that fronts
to the north of this image so where it
fronts onto this parking area here so
the elevations of the proposals um have
um you know gray cladding so it's an
industrial appearance unit
um the units is up we'll look at we'll
look at the side elevations have brick
Gable ends facing into the access road
to the site with some uh with some
glazing as well
um just important to note on this
particular set of units you can see that
units seven and eight which if I click
through you'll now see on the left hand
side of the image which are the ones
that are closest to railway Terrace are
obviously set down in height
specifically because the relationship
with the railway Terrace but as you've
seen from the images there is a
significant change in land level which
we consider is is particularly relevant
when looking at the impact on those
properties
so this is the elevation that fronts on
the internal access roads this is the
style of the brick Gable with the
glazing um the sort of floor to ceiling
glazing that's proposed or close to 40
and glazing at the front of the access
road
and then the other side is the more
industrial gray cladding
look at those units they are
um
they are single story but they are sort
of double height internally so there's
no internal mezzanines that are proposed
as part of the scheme so then just
looking at the First full row of
properties if we take the elevation
that's facing to the north here you can
see again same design of properties
um important to note on the right hand
side of this image you can see where the
retaining wall is and then the changing
level with the embankment where those
trees are so the idea is that the
embankment is not changed by The
Proposal the development goes up to it
with the retaining wall but it is
retained
and then looking at the other side so
now the embankment is going to go on the
left hand side of the image so with the
properties on Tivoli Park Avenue on the
left of this image so you can see the
change in land level
and then moving through the site again
same design for the the Gable lens and
same design for the inside moving
through then the designs are the same
for all these units and then looking at
the midsection again so you can see this
section of the site on the left hand
side there's more of a distance for the
neighboring properties because of the
the embankment itself and again that's
now on the right hand side there and
then on the and then on the left hand
side and then the last lot of units
actually these ones obviously not quite
so so wide and not quite so many units
again on the right hand side you can see
the embankment and then on the left hand
side which obviously then is the back of
the site which faces towards the other
uh industrial open storage use that's to
the rear of the site
and then this is the side elevation
so in terms of uh considerations
character and appearance
um
obviously the design is in industrial in
nature it's not a designated area in
terms of Conservation area and we do
think the design is appropriate for an
employment site given the collection of
uses that are around there in terms of
living conditions of neighboring
properties given the change in land
level as well as the orientation of
properties and of the commercial units
or where they face inside the site don't
consider there's going to be any
overlooking there are no side windows
that face towards the Residential
Properties and given the distance from
rear windows as well as that changing
levels it's not considered they would
result in any sense of enclosure to
neighboring properties now one of the
issues that came up during the course
the application was the use proposed was
slightly unclear which resulted in some
additional consultation
and one of the suggestions was that they
were proposing to have what was the old
B2 uses actually sorry still B2 which is
General Industrial which would raise
concerns given the layout and the
potential impact on neighboring
properties so it's these are downers as
I mentioned the light industrial units
but we still did receive a a noise
impact assessment on the basis of what
the impact could be on Residential
Properties this was submitted following
comments from the environmental health
team they looked at the background noise
levels and the outcome of that was that
the impact on on residents would be
acceptable subject however to
conditioning of opening hours so
specifically there is a planning
condition that's recommended and to
members for restrictions on eight sorry
on nine till six pm so 9 A.M to 6 P.M
Monday to Friday and 9 A.M to 4 P.M on
Saturday
um and on that basis it's not considered
that um the officers have any objection
to the impact on residential immunity
in terms of environmental matters
um there's a series of contaminated land
conditions that are proposed
specifically because of the previous
uses on site there was a phase one desk
based survey which was submitted as part
of the application however for any
development on the site requires a phase
to intrusive investigation and there are
grampian conditions proposed which would
include any remediation that's required
to get up to the standard necessary for
a commercial unit before any development
should take place on the site there's
also a condition which proposes a
control on on piling in terms of
foundations for potential to create
Pathways to the aquifer
terms of ecology and we have received
comments from KCC biodiversity that are
in the report obviously the existing
site the majority of it is as you've
seen hard surface with some some grass
growth however it's the boundaries of
the site that are the key elements here
and obviously
um whilst the boundaries are being
retained we still expect sites such as
this to provide a net gained
biodiversity and therefore is proposed
for a series of conditions one of which
includes a a lighting plan to be
submitted if for any external lighting
to ensure that it's designed appropriate
to the The Guidance with regards to
biodiversity impacts for for lighting as
well as that it would be required in any
reserve matters to provide details of
the enhancements proposed and obviously
there is some open space to enhance the
existing sort of uh hedgerows well if
not Hedgerow sorry the existing Bank
areas which could have additional
planting proposed on them on that basis
with conditions we consider the impact
on ecology to be acceptable
in terms of drainage the previous
application was accompanied by a flood
risk assessment and the applicant has
resubmitted that flood risk assessment
which KCC have looked at to see whether
or not the principles of what's being
proposed is acceptable
fundamentally the previous assessment
done on the old scheme related to
permeable Paving for around that
building because you'll recall from the
image pretty much the whole site was
covered in building
and in this instance what's being
proposed is that any any hard surfacing
would be permanently paved to allow for
infiltration through with certain
controls being required within obviously
buildings in terms of runoff however
again this would be subject to grampian
conditions saying no development should
take place until details of both foul
water which obviously is subject to a
separate consensus regime in terms of
the water infrastructure act but to also
include surface water drainage that that
scheme is provided and obviously it goes
hand in hand with a landscaping scheme
which would obviously have to come
forward at Reserve matters
so in terms of Highways considerations
the site is highly sustainable it's
obviously in walking distance of the
station and highways have looked at this
you know looked at the application and
raised issues initially with the
transport assessment that was submitted
obviously members will have seen from
the photos the condition they access is
uh far from ideal in terms of the
surfacing obviously this would you know
resurface that access and provide
pedestrian footway either side to allow
for safer Crossing than currently exists
um in terms of
issues within the site in terms of
parking levels that has been looked at
obviously by Casey highways and consider
that both the proportion of parking per
unit but also the addition of visitor
spaces is considered to be sufficient
they're also on-street controls on the
road outside the access yellow lines on
both sides now admittedly that I
appreciate that doesn't stop people
parking on yellow lines but it is a
matter that's not controlled by planning
legislation it's required by parking
enforcement so on that basis it's not
considered that the development itself
would result in unauthorized parking as
a as a a definitive outcome from the
basis of the amount of parking that's
provided on the site
um again visibility splays uh it's not
changing
um particularly the sprays that are
existing on the access at the moment so
that is considered to be acceptable
um in terms of mention that's been made
of
um
turning
um on the site
um this wasn't an issue that was raised
by highways
um in terms of turning this is showing
if I go to this image so I made I talked
about the hoarding that runs around this
site in particular you have the access
point
um here this gate here which runs to the
open storage at the very rear of the
site where we saw that image and then we
have the access that runs down to the
other industrial units on the left hand
side
so this area is not is not changing in
terms of
um you know there's no changes proposed
to this it's still it's going to be hard
surfaced on the plan so if I go back to
the plan you'll see
that that section there
and obviously turning has been provided
for vehicles using these units
themselves obviously there is there's no
restriction on the vehicles that could
use this site
um so
um you know in terms of the point
earlier about a larger vehicle
delivering to one of these particular
units then there's no restriction on any
vehicle coming down here it is a point
obviously that highways have looked at
they've looked at the existing situation
on site they've looked at the ability of
vehicles to turn on site and accessing
um the units that you can find
further down in this area here to the
north of to the top of the image and
again it's not it has not been raised as
an issue as a point of objection from
cases the highways that would indicate
that there is going to be a substantial
harm to highway safety from Vehicles
having to reverse out down that road I'm
not aware of how much that occurs at the
moment if it if you know it may be that
it doesn't occur because of the space
but the space that's available is
actually in this turning area here and
also if I go back to the aerial image
sorry I'm just going to skip through all
of these
bear with me just so we can look at the
aerial image
so that members fully get an idea of
the existing relationship with the sites
there we go so this whole area here
is obviously accessed via the gate and
then you've got this collection of of
vehicles that the areas at the moment
obviously actually you've got on Google
they've indicated where the can-do
timber supplies unit is and that is
obviously accessed via that triangle of
land so it's not considered that this
development in itself would result in a
significant worsening of Highway Safety
on the base of of what has been proposed
um
to pick up the point that's been raised
with regards to access to railway
Terrace
so
The Proposal
does not include any new access to
railway Terrace via this site this is
dealt within the report
the issue here is that obviously what
we're talking about is a private site I
don't think there's any argument that
there could potentially be a betterment
if there wasn't additional access that
was provided to railway terrorists
however there is no requirement on this
development nor is there harm that we
would be able to refuse the application
on from not providing it this
development does not make the existing
situation any worse by virtue of the
fact that this site is effectively
closed off an unavailable for access at
the moment and so in terms of actually
requiring an access through this site
it's not justifiable as a planning
condition and it wouldn't meet the tests
of condition accordingly and and
officers could not sustain a reason for
refusal to peel on those grounds
um so overall
um we consider that the proposal would
be uh in accordance with the local plan
and specifically obviously the
employment allocations and there are a
number of safeguarding conditions that
would certainly be required to ensure
that any impacts were controlled and
mitigated appropriately and the
recommendation is to approve
thank you
thank you Ian I moved the officer's
recommendation is adopted could the vice
chair please second oh second nature
thank you Council Coleman cook members
councilor Auburn
yes thank you chair
um
I've got no problem at all
with the design of the structures
as an industrial site and if
it has no no effects on the local on the
local media and amenity in that respect
um I do have concerns in relation to
the the top
eight units which are the closest to
railway Terrace because I'm just looking
at that it just it really does seem that
everything's been crammed into that site
that it seems that there's too many
units on that site and certainly my
knowledge of industrial units
is that uh they'll be overwhelmed with
cars be overwhelmed with it I've I've
decided deliveries except etc etc so my
concern really chair is is on the
um impact that those top units will have
on Railway Terrace
um certainly it's a bit if I remember
correctly in fact maybe Mr limister will
remind me or put me straight but he just
said I was going to do some work around
the um around that kind of semi
semi-circle in relation to
um
The Verge or whatever you want to call
it there and that gives me concern in
relation to the trees because as uh as a
resident has said they're vital
to them for them to retain to uh
keep noise out to a certain degree
if this is not possible
for those top eight not to be there and
also that's what they if they're not
there that releases for further parking
so the vehicles don't have to come down
or into site so they can be parked up
there because what will happen is that
the people who work in the units will
park on that will park on the on the two
spaces and there'll be nowhere for
visitors to actually go so I think that
parking area used needs to be bigger at
the top
um
but
should this not be the case and members
decide to uh
um would decide to approve it as is
can I ask
um Mr Livingston if there was any
thought of any acoustic fencing being
put up
um on the uh
if you like on the
Railway cherish side of the
um tree line or indeed on the other side
as well which won't damage them but
would keep any noise so it's just just a
question on that thank you chair
foreign
so if I
sorry let me just go back uh all the way
back through the images
so the proposal there we go so the
proposal is to retain all of the trees
um and obviously the detail of the
landscaping and how
the trees would effectively be
safeguarding would be part of the of the
reserve matters application because it's
Landscaping
um obviously the council could look if
there was any concern about those trees
and and both the amenity but also the
sort of screening that they provide then
certainly we can look at a TPO on those
trees probably a group order because
individually they're probably not of
necessary a standards to TPO them
individually
um we'd certainly look to try and secure
it through the planning application
itself when the reserve matters would
come in
um to your point about acoustic fencing
so the noise impact assessment looked at
the background noise levels and then
looked at what this projection would be
with with the units that are there it
wasn't considered by environmental
health that you would need an acoustic
fence along there basically mainly on
the on the the operating times so that
that opening hours condition meaning
that you can't do it before nine you
can't do it after six pm on that basis
and it wasn't considered a necessity in
terms of the parking in that area
again
in in terms of losing units from there
the parking level has been considered to
be acceptable
um obviously for a refusal on parking
grounds um there has to be a sort of
evidence severe impact on the network
and the difficulty here is in justifying
that is is the on-street controls and
the and again the fact that that you
know they are adding visitor parking
different bits and pieces but I I accept
what you're saying in terms of it's
closer to the trees at that point in the
site
um because of the well because the shape
of the site really
yeah
in that case uh chair could I ask then
um for uh Mr Livingston to consider
when the
landscape proposals come in should this
be a be approved that they consider
acoustic fencing
that sounds fine thank you councilor
thank you Captain Crittenden
thank you
um
I
know this area possibly well I'm not
particularly from Margate but I
certainly know the main road entrance
um near where Railway Terrace is one
question I'm just trying to remember the
name of the road that the other exit
comes into cool same time what is
All Saints Avenue it is okay I thought
it would be thank you
um I'm looking at that and I've worked
on Industrial Estates
um in in various ways and I think that
the parking is going to be inadequate
there isn't particularly for for staff
among other things and if those light
industrial units have got their own
Vehicles as well
um now I appreciate that it's actually
near a railway station and it's on a bus
route but that doesn't mean to say that
people are actually going to use public
transport
so I am concerned that there is
inadequate parking and I am also
concerned about those turning angles as
well as raised by the resident at the
beginning
so I like Council Auburn I think there
are too many units in there and I think
those things need to be looked at again
uh thank you Council Hart
thank you
um the concerns I have with this are
equal to my other accounts is not uh
could have done and Auburn I don't think
there's enough parking um we all know
that these sites have enormous amounts
of visitors and staff who work there but
the other thing I have is if you're at
the end bottom end of that screen
how the hell are you going to get an
Arctic to turn into there
um and get back out and that is an issue
because these places will have
um articulated lorries turning up and if
they say they're not they are because
these people do have if you have a
double glazing company for example
they're just going to have architects of
glass turning up and they're not just
going to have a little Transit van
turning up with uh 30 or 40 tons of
glass
um so I do have concerns about that and
also I do have concerns about this trees
um I do agree they should have a a TPO
order a group TPO order on them but I
also think that
somebody has to be
liable for the maintenance of those
trees because one company who has unit
number eight isn't going to look after
trees 13 14 and 15 for example they
won't want to take on that cost so I
think that needs to be put into the plan
as well who's going to maintain the
boundary lines
um but apart from that I'd like to know
how wide that road is it's going
alongside so that there is turning room
for an articulated vehicle because I've
driven articulated vehicles and they do
take some maneuvering to get into a good
space and not everybody's very good at
it and you know some of them are huge
absolutely huge thank you thank you
Council Hart uh Council bayford
our speaker tonight
um said that he thinks it's it's
impossible for large vehicles to to turn
whereas the report States
um
no objection this is KCC highways no
objection is raised regarding the layout
for vehicles maneuvering within the site
to be able to leave the site in a
forward gear
so is that assuming that they are not
large vehicles
do you wish
um yeah the comment we've got is exactly
as as you say I mean I think that that
the point that I suppose I I cannot
clarify is the the transport assessment
obviously as mentioned is based on a uh
it appears to use and actually you can
see in the image you see there you can
see some some tracking plans that are
done there on the basis of a 13 meter
vehicle obviously the concerns that have
been raised relate to well what if there
is a much larger vehicle that's using to
serve these units obviously these units
are not large industrial units
um however in terms of the consideration
obviously
um you know highways would be expected
to look at what you'd get on an
industrial site and indeed those units
at the back there and obviously mentions
has been made of those the timber Supply
units which obviously actually access
directly off that triangle at the moment
that you can see here so in terms of
turning for other businesses on the
industrial estate isn't changing by
virtue of this the issue though is
whether or not this site makes adequate
arrangements for turning of larger
vehicles or not and clearly this is a
concern that I appreciate a number of
members have got
um so I think if we carry on and then
we'll come back on this point they could
cancel a wing
thank you I mean I shared I share the
same concerns I mean I think we agreed
that this is a good use of of the site
and and would tidy the site up because
the site does look to be a bit
ramshackled uh but I think there's too
many in there uh I Ian can you give the
the elevations because we can't see the
height of the lower buildings at the top
in relation to uh Railway Terrace uh
have we got the height of the height of
Railway Terrace and the height of
normally we get we get an elevation
where you see the next door property and
the section yeah so the image that we've
got
um here is the well if I go back it
might just be giving us the height of
the the lower buildings yeah so it's
giving the height of the lower buildings
that then shows that if um in this image
here where you've got
um the the three and then the five yeah
if you can see that so the five
you can see then it changed you've then
got a gap and then you've got a change
in level so this is the image of then
the two units seven and eight which are
the nearest ones there and you can see a
change in level of of five meters now
the report talks about uh the distance
and if I go back sorry to the
site plan showing the neighboring
properties sorry I'm gonna have to go
all the way through some images bear
with me it's my fault no no no this is
an important point
um so you can see again you can just see
again the change in levels that we've
got but if you look at this image here
you can see that the the properties that
are closest to the end property in
Railway Terrace the railway Railway
tours the closest property is
7.7.3 meters I think it is from the
corner to the the corner of this of this
development but because of the two meter
height difference and the fact that it's
the reduced units and scale excuse me
it's not considered in terms of the
in terms of sense of enclosure we
usually look and make sure that their
views out and over and they're not
actually directly affecting habitable
rooms so in this case the orientation of
the properties is considered to be
sufficient but mainly it's it's the
change in level uh specifically
I mean I do think there's too many
there's too many units there we all know
that industrial units I use the pythons
industrial unit quite a lot and it's
scattered with cars parked all over the
place
and articulated lorries regularly visit
regularly have trouble coming out so I
don't know whether it's it's not a
direct refusal but but just suggesting
that they lose a pair of units off of
each end and and two of the nearest ones
up by Railway Terrace to to give to
provide more parking and to enable
better turning for larger vehicles that
are clearly going to visit the site
that's my concern uh I think we all
agreed it would be a good use of that
land to thank you councilor I mean I
think we've got to consider
what we got in front of us at the moment
and there's been as Mr Livingston said
it can be looked at now Council Ghana
thank you yeah I mean I share concerns
about the number units on the on the
site I can't
it I mean it's overcrowding as far as if
it's houses it would be overcrowding and
if I mean hopefully
we'd like to see successful businesses
in in the units and if all of those
units are successfully occupied and busy
and all make doing good business that's
going to be busier than Piccadilly
Circus going in and out of there and
there'll be all sorts of bands trying to
get in Lobby's trying to get out it just
seems over
overpopulated to me
um
and the other thing I'm really just a
little bit unclear about is the
relationship
with the existing site which is on that
picture next to the railway
Railway isn't it well on the picture
that was just saying yeah there so they
although you're saying they're not
related in terms of um
of vehicles coming in out and
articulated Lloyd's turning as far as I
can see there is only one access point
to both sides isn't there which is on
the plan you showed us it's obviously
going to be re looks like it's going to
be relayed road with a pathway but that
is the road that will be used not just
for this site will it it will be used
for the whole lot
so there will be where there are
lorries or whatever there are going into
the site that's already there they'll be
coming through that entrance on the site
that was on the final plan
so I mean I'm
I'm pretty unhappy about the whole the
whole um the whole application and as
you say we can only deal we can't make
suggestions we deal with this this as we
see it so um I I'm currently minded to
to recommend refusal of this and I'm not
and it might help me to
it might help me to better visualize all
of this if we actually were able to go
on site and see how it or everything
relates
to each other so I think that that would
be my favorite option thank you uh thank
you Council Garner councilor I'll bring
you back thank you
um Ian was saying at the beginning that
they're not two-story units but they are
in height but there's no mezzanine
um so they're not going to overlook
those properties but if the owner of
that property decides to put one in so
you can put another steal in and put a
mezzanine on there for storage or to
turn into an office what is stopping
them or is it going to be a condition of
planning that they can't
um so in terms of in terms of adding
floor space
um in terms of adding a mezzanine
um I'm trying to remember in terms of
permitted development I believe that you
could add a you could add a steel
forsake as you say storage the issue is
because the particularly thinking of
impact on living conditions in terms of
overlooking all the windows are facing
into the side so there are no first
floor Windows facing towards the
property of the side in terms of
increasing the floor space
um there wouldn't necessarily be any
objection to that but obviously that I
suppose could be factored into the
question of do you increase the amount
of deliveries the need for parking on
the site so um if it was considered
appropriate we would we could look at
whether or not a condition would be
possible to restrict obviously we've got
plan condition which says you've got to
build it in accordance with these plans
but the question is whether or not an
insertion of a mezzanine is actually
development under the planning act and
wouldn't require permission on its own
and I don't believe it would we will
look into that whilst the discussion
goes on just to check that point
also my question is a twofold really
excuse me so if if one person or one
company has one unit would they be able
to make the other unit next to them into
that into it
an adjoining unit so they effectively
they're doubling their spaces so
therefore they will need
um bigger vehicles to come and service
their area so it's all part and parcel
of the same thing really
yeah
um
I don't believe that would be
development under the planning act so I
don't think it would require permission
the the the question is whether there's
an intensification which results in a
material change of use or not I don't
believe that it would require uh consent
uh definitively again the point would be
whether or not that would come about if
it came about after the development was
fully completed and therefore the
planning condition was complied with I
don't think it would necessarily need a
subsequent application again this is
something that could be restricted by
virtue of condition the question is what
the ground would be for that condition
and whether or not there is harm from
that happening uh if a bigger unit was
made and I don't necessarily think that
there's an automatic harm that's created
by that because obviously
that unit then has
two lots of parking spaces from what it
had originally for example if we're just
talking about parking for example
uh thank you Ian councilman you wish to
come back yes thank you chair um
obviously I'm mindful about the um the
use of the site
um and as and as members have spoken uh
this is an industrial site and
that's what it will be
um are mindful as well chair of
thinking forward as to should we refuse
it on whatever grounds
that um it will go to appeal and it's
likely that we would probably not
succeed at appeal so I'm I'm mindful of
that what it
through your chair it would it be
um could we ask this to be put back to
officers
to negotiate with the applicants to
reduce the amount of units
which would then probably allow an
increase of vehicle movement with within
the site
and also to then look at
um uh acoustic
fencing etc etc
and parking so
um to save because the way it's going
here is likely that we're likely to
refuse this application so I'm just
saying is is that a way forward
thank you as always uh councilman you
have a very good point there and I will
pass over to Ian again
um
we've talked before about uh when
there's been the question of whether or
not we should move to a site visit if
the discussion um is going that
particular way for example if enough
people in the committee mention it
um we haven't hit the magic 7 number to
hit the half of members that have
particularly raised this but I do
understand that those that have spoken
have spoke very clearly about the
concerns on this matter
um it is a consideration for the chair
and vice chair because obviously we have
a motion on the table that if we're not
voting on that motion or sorry if
members are not voting on that motion
then that motion has to be withdrawn and
then a new motion to be proposed
um I understand the concerns that that
members have raised and I may have
already drafted that precise motion that
counts that Auburn has has been talking
about whilst members have been speaking
um but I think it's it's a it's a
decision for the chair whether or not we
don't proceed with the vote on the
current motion that's in front of
us uh thank you Ian put the ball in my
court
um
paid for yeah that's a that's a bit of a
type one cancer Auburn
um what I will say
um
and I know all I'm going to say I do
know this site very well and I know I I
don't I'm nothing again any influence
because I don't and I think you know
that since I've been your chair
um and it's very interesting what I've
heard tonight
um I have my own feelings because I do
know the site very very well for reasons
uh past years on what was on that site
and that's showing my age again which I
often do
but
um I hear what members are saying here
tonight about
overcrowding and so forth and the
Turning of vehicles
I feel it would be fair
two members to
withdraw this application if the vice
chair
agrees
or the motion sorry
um so I will propose the motion is
withdrawn I'd like the vice chair to
second that oh second nature and it's
been brought forward about a site visit
yes and I'll bring him in back so I
remember would have to propose a motion
but listening to the discussion
um we've had a one mention of site visit
but it it's pretty clear from those
members that have spoken and had five or
six
um that the issue primarily is about the
number of units the Turning for vehicles
within the site and the level of parking
there are other issues that have been
raised but those are the key ones that I
think there is click and census on so
if a member was minded to to move the
motion for uh defer and delegate to
officers to seek additional information
on turning within the site for larger
vehicles and a reduction in the number
of units to increase parking and turning
and bring that back then to members for
consideration and determination
let's do it
thank you cancer Alban you've heard that
and it's been seconded by Council
Crittenden two members agree
foreign
I'm
just saying when that does come back
if it does come back in a different
format it still might help us if we have
had a site visit to actually see the
site so we can see how how this all fits
together but it certainly helped me
anyway
and if I've no one else agrees then
we're going up on but I would like to
suggest that we would if I suggest you
buy some timber in the hood yard up
there you can have a look at the site
members we've had a proposal to defer
and delegate and I think it's been
explained very well and again in a very
good debate um and seconded those who
agree
those against
that has been carried and thank you Ian
thank you for it thank you members
chair sorry to um
I think some of our uh public I was
going to understand what's what's just
happened here
right to to the uh yes I will ask our
plan applications management explain
exactly what has happened with committee
and the decision made so you're aware
um so the application hasn't been
determined this evening so it's been put
back to officers to seek changes to the
plans once those changes uh have been
received we would look to consult
residents on those plans
um if changes are not not received then
it would have to come back to planning
committee for a determination because
it's been called in and in the same way
if we do get amended plans in and
officers consider that Chimes we've got
members have asked for this evening then
again it will then be reported back to
planning committee for determination and
again in the same way as in this meeting
anyone that's written in will be
notified by letter and given the ability
we'll try and we'll try and put it as a
schedule item if people do want to speak
on that
that's it no I'm sorry I I I'm sorry I
don't I know it's quite blunt saying
that too sir but um no we're not allowed
to um I'll I'll be told off again that
uh but I hope you understand hope you
understand the decision and um yeah so
you will be notified and thank you for
your attendance there tonight uh agenda
item 4B which is land set south of the
Millennium Way broadstairs uh speaking
in favor of this application is a Mr
Thorpe Mr Thorpe
I believe you're there
you have three minutes
thank you thank you members my name is
Luke Thorpe here to represent lnt care
developments and highlight the benefits
of our proposed investment
we are the country's leading Care Home
developer and have extensive experience
in developing and operating Care Homes
across the country
of our partner company ideal Care Homes
operational homes all have achieved
ratings of either good or outstanding by
the Care Quality Commission
we are proposing to regenerate this site
which has stood vacant and underutilized
for over 20 years to provide a care home
for the local community and people with
a local connection
the site was recently split into
employment and housing allocations which
created a significant barrier for
delivering feasible and viable
development in this location
our proposals addressed this and meet
the council's policy aspirations to
provide much needed residential
accommodation
and boost job growth and economic
performance
principally by providing a purpose-built
high quality accommodation for older
people who need general or dementia care
creating over 50 jobs training and
career development opportunities
and boosting the local economy through
greater spending at local supply chain
and service businesses
this will benefit local people looking
for work and local older people who will
have a greater choice of care
accommodation to meet their changing
needs
a consequent effect will be more local
homes released into the market for
aspiring families and first-time buyers
in terms of the environmental benefits
the proposed design reflects the nature
of its use and the character of the
local area complementing existing homes
within the community and providing an
appropriate relationship with neighbors
pollinating sensory and habitat friendly
Landscaping will attractively frame the
building and establish healthy and
biodiverse Immunity spaces
to mitigate the effects of climate
change the care home has been designed
to be water efficient and generates a
majority of its energy needs on site
using solar power and ground Source
Heating
parking will be provided within the site
including for electric vehicles with the
amount being more than suitable for the
number of staff and visitors likely to
be present at any one time
alongside this staff and visitors will
be encouraged to walk cycle and use
public transport through the
implementation of our travel plan
the benefits available to the local
community environment and economy are
substantial but most importantly the
proposals offer what local older people
deserve most a sense of community and
home a great quality of life and care
and a comfortable healthy and familiar
living environment
I am happy to say that the proposals and
recommendation before you are highly
appropriate and deliverable
this investment is not speculative and
the associated benefits can be achieved
within the next two years if this
application is approved today
I therefore trust that members will
support this application and vote in
favor of the office's recommendation
thank you
thank you very much Mr Thorpe speaking
with concerns of this application is Mr
Heaney Mr Heaney good evening to you
okay you have a three minutes to speak
my main reasons for objecting to this
proposal is the woefully inadequate and
lack of on-site parking as proposed in
the plans of only 20 spaces
for development of this size in my
opinion this is inadequate
the pro the proposed on-site spaces will
probably be used by vehicles of the
essential permanent support staff
without including carers
this is a large site of us with the
equivalent of a small Hospital
the facilities that would be
where the where the people would take up
the spaces will be care home management
staff
on-site catering staff
on-site maintenance
laundry staff
cleaners administrative support
financial support
on-site trainers and ad hoc visits
based on the England national Care Home
average of 1.65 carers per res residence
assuming 66 residents this equates to
approximately 109 carers
if the prop if the site was full
where exactly are these employees going
to park their cars
there is no public transport
and people do not cycle to work
as stated in my letter of objection
these vehicles are likely to be parked
in the nearby housing estate roads close
by where I and others live
more on-site parking needs to be
provided before this is approved
KCC highways carried out a road and
parking investigation
on a previous planning application
to to ensure conformity in dealing with
this matter
regarding parking in this Junction area
an updated highways report should be
arranged
bearing in mind
the likely extra Vehicles Park both
sides of Northwood Road and the Silvers
however clear guidance was given by Kent
highways at the time in regard to
another planning application
which involved traffic movement and
parking in that area
I would suggest that committee members
may wish to look at look up plan an
application number F backslash th
backslash thirteen zero six zero one
under transport and parking
KCC highways have given clear guidance
on this matter in this specific Junction
area
which be even more relevant today as
traffic volumes have increased since
that date of the last inspection
thank you for listening thank you Mr
Haney I will ask the planning officer
which I believe is Emma to outline this
application thank you
thank you chairman uh this is the
application site outlined in red on this
plan here so we've got Northwood Road on
the right hand side and Millennium Ray
running along the top of this plan and
you can see Northwood Court this
location here and some retail units in
this location here and Residential
Properties opposite the site
so this is an aerial view of the site so
this is the site in this location here
so it includes this building and this
area of land up to these boundaries here
you can see in terms of its location and
these are this is the existing Tescos in
the middle of Westward so it's on the
edge of the town center and the other
existing retail units to the south of
that and here is the Kent Innovation
Center and the former Christchurch
University buildings in this location
here and again you can see residential
on the east side of the road
so the site lies within an area in the
Sonic local plan that's allocated for
both residential use and employment use
so this is the application Site Area
here so the purple area is the
employment allocation and so this part
of the site Falls within the employment
allocation and this area here is the
housing allocation so you can see in
terms of the actual
um
site location the blue area is the Town
Center so this is the westward in this
location here to the north of Millennium
Way is the Strategic employment site and
then to the south of Millennium Way is
residential so this originally all
formed part of the employment site but
through the um current local plan this
area here has been deallocated from
employment use and is now in residential
use and you can see that that has
extended up to Northwood Road on the
right hand side here
so this is just a closer view of the
application sites I've outlined it in
Red so you can clearly see the actual
outline of the site so again you can see
the area in purple is the employment use
so in terms of the employment use the
policy covering this is policy e01 of
the Senate local plan and this actually
looks to retain employment uses on the
site that fall within storage offices
and light industrial uses so
um in terms of the actual residential
use that again the area hatched in brown
policy h01 covers this area and this
looks to retain the area for residential
use and and doesn't permit any
alternative use on the land so the
applications brought before members as a
departure to these policies
so this is the site
um here so this is an existing building
on the site this was this one part of a
1999 consent for for telecommunication
buildings on the site so only one of
them has been built which is this one
here
um it was never completed and you'll see
some photos in a moment inside the
building so it doesn't have any
utilities inside the building it doesn't
have a staircase between the floors and
there's no current Windows within it so
it's been it's a disuse building it's
been there for 20 years and there's been
lots of marketing of the site and the
site has never come forward for
employment use there's also a condition
attached to the consent from the 1999
consent that limits the um use of the
site to telecommunications only so if
they if any alternative development were
to come forward on this site they would
actually require permission to move away
from a telecommunications use
so this view is taken from Northwood
Road looking towards the site
um you can see that there's a currently
a landscape area to the front of the
site it's quite overgrown to the front
and this again is taken with the
building on the right hand side so all
of this area that you can see here is
all part of the application site you can
see a psychopath running along this part
of the pavement
again take a view taken so again you can
now see the closest Residential
Properties are in Northwood Road so
there's a row of Terrace units in this
location here of two-story and height
and again a quote a few of the sites so
the site is quite overgrown at the
moment and it's got quite a few small
sapling trees on the site
um
and then this is now looking to the
right hand side so the application site
is this building here so this is
um Northwood courts on the corner and
you can see the Innovation Center in the
distance here so in terms of scale and
height of Builders you can see this is a
three-story building of quite a modern
flat roof design so compared to the
Residential Properties that you saw to
the West which were quite traditional
looking building so there's a bit of a
range in terms of design and materials
and scale of buildings in this part of
the of of the road
this is now taken from the rear of the
site so this is again the existing
building within the site that they're
looking to demolish through this
application
and this is the gap between the building
so again this building on the right hand
side is a building we're looking to
demolish and you can see the Gap
um to Northwood court on the left-hand
side here
and then a bit further back so some
areas are hard to stand into the rear
but also it's been it's quite overgrown
there's been areas of where there's been
some fly tipping around here and then
further back again so this this building
here is a garage I think in the report
I'd said that this was actually
um a workshop but actually it's actually
a retail use that sells um car parts so
it's actually not a workshop use but a
retail unit this here is a substation
which is
um retained and it doesn't fall within
the application site
and again this is the the substation
with the the
um application building in the distance
there
and then this is looking so this is the
rear of the site with the um
so this is within the application site
with the employment buildings the right
hand side and this is looking towards
the access road that then leads on to
Millennium Way so um as part of the the
1999 consent this formed the access road
that led into the um the site but as
part of the deallocation of this land
this now actually forms part of the
residential allocation and is not no
longer part of the employment allocation
so this is another view of the access
taken from the access road looking into
the site so this is the actual site
itself
and then now back inside the site just
showing you
um some of the suction trees and the
area that's quite overgrown and then
this is the southern boundary of the
site where there's quite a few trees
that um are looking to be retained as
part of the scheme so it's a bit of a
landscape buffer along this southern
boundary
this is inside the building so it's
quite dark as I said there's no
utilities inside the building so you can
see it's it's never been used
um
and again another view of it so it's
just got some storage material inside
and this is showing the staircase that
started constructing but has never been
complete so there's no access between
the ground first floor so it's not a
building that can easily
um suddenly accommodate an employment
use that a company would have to come in
and do quite a lot of work inside this
building to make it usable
so the application is for a 66 bed care
home it's a two-story building
um this is a proposed site plan showing
the development so the proposal was for
a new vehicular access onto Northwood
Road in this location here so Central to
the site so this is this is the location
here of that existing building and this
is the proposed access
um you can see it's it's quite a large
building but it does have quite a lot of
space around it
and plans were amended during this
Mission which have increased the
distance to the rear boundary so there's
now 15 meters distance from the rear
elevation to the rear boundary and then
again 15 meters um to the side here to
the substation and then a distance of 19
meters to the neighboring boundary here
you can see in this location here is the
landscape buffer that you saw within the
photo so that's the area that they're
looking to retain through these
applications and along the front of the
site The Proposal is to plant some new
trees and have a new a new landscape
baffle on that Frontage which as you saw
from the photos there's quite a few
tree-lined well there's three-line
Street along there so lots of trees up
to the front of Norfolk court and the
Innovation Center so that would continue
the tree planting along the road make it
appear in keeping in terms of the
Landscaping of the site
uh so to the front of the site is the
parking area so the proposal is for 25
parking spaces
um and of those there would be
um
three two disabled spaces and three
would be electric vehicle charging
spaces and there's like also a cycle
storage area in this location here and
the refuse storage is in this location
here
so in terms of the actual building
whilst as I mentioned the large in scale
is set back
um quite a good depth from the road also
in terms of the shape of the building
it's because of this shape it's enabled
the ridge line of the building to be
kept quite low and has resulted in quite
staggered elevations so you'll see that
now in the elevations so this is the um
the proposed front elevation facing onto
Northwood Road so you can see it's a
two-story building it's got a central
Gable feature and then to both ends
there's a projecting
um
section with a pitch roof you can see
there's in terms of the materials it's a
mix of red brick and render some dark
gray windows and
um dark concrete roof
so in terms of the materials it's it's
more in keeping with the Residential
Properties in the street more so than
the commercial buildings to the north
then this is the rear elevation so it's
quite a good amount of glazing within
the elevations there's also proposing
some cladding as well which will help to
break up the width of the elevations
and then these are the side elevations
so in terms of the views as you're
approaching the building from either
direction you'll see quite a small
element here with a gap behind it in
this area here is then set back into the
main bulk of the building
and then again this is the other
elevation so this is the elevation from
the neighboring property side to the
South
foreign
impact on neighbors there's the 20 meter
distance between the proposed first
floor Windows within the side elevation
here and the nearest neighboring
properties the fact that the landscape
buffer has been retained as well as this
distance and the fact that the windows
that are proposed face in the the
neighboring properties are actually only
um hallway Windows which aren't
habitable room windows it's not
considered there would be a significant
impact on overlooking from the
development to the neighbors in terms of
noise and disturbance there's a 25 meter
distance between the parking area and
number 100 Northwood Road and it's
considered this distance again is
significant
significant enough to reduce any
significant impact from noise and
disturbance and also it's to the front
of the property as well not for the rear
near the um their Garden
um in terms of the rear we have
considered the impact upon any future
Housing Development within the housing
allocation site and this has resulted to
the the request that the building be set
further away from the boundary so now
with this 15 meter distance it's
considered that should be acceptable to
prevent any future impact on
um Residential Properties within that
housing allocation area
and to the the commercial buildings to
the north there's a 28 meter distance
and as I said that's they're actually
only retail units and they're only open
up till 5 30 in the evening so it's not
considered there'll be any noise and
disturbance from that on the future
residents of the building either so
there's quite a substantial immunity
space around in the building for future
residents
um and therefore the liver conditions
concerns are officer to be acceptable in
terms of parking as you heard there's
some concerns from residents regarding
the parking provision so 25 spaces are
are proposed with the cycle store as
well for
um for eight parking spaces
um KC highways haven't raised any
concerns with this it's it's considered
that the occupies of the building which
is a care use are unlikely to have
vehicles themselves so it's only likely
to be staff and visitors that would be
visiting the building and based on the
fact that the staff would be rotated
um and sort of over different times not
all there at once and the fact that
there would be
visitors again different times of the
day highways have looked at this and
considered that there wouldn't be a huge
impact on on Highway Safety or on the
network from
um from these vehicles and the transport
statement has been submitted sort of
explains that they've also missed a
travel plan as well with it that looks
at sustainable travel to and from the
site and that's been conditioned
um
sorry I just nipped down whilst I'm
talking about the highway bits of this
in terms of the access and this is the
proposed access into the site there's
visibility sprays of the 43 meters by
2.5 which is considered acceptable in
this location and they're also proposing
um pedestrian Crossing points at this
point here along the footpath so again
highways have raised no concerns of that
so this is a plan just showing the
building within the street scene so it's
not a plan that's up for approval but
it's an addictive plan but he's showing
the scale of the building in relation to
neighboring development and again you
can see the space in between the
proposed building and the neighboring
properties
um it's quite a lot of space around the
building therefore is not considered
that there would be a significant impact
on the street scene because whilst the
building is large the site is large
enough to accommodate this building
without any significant impact and in
terms of the ridge line you can see it
actually falls below the three-story
height of um uh
um the duff would call on the corner
um
so the main considerations with this
application is is the principal issues
so
um the site as I mentioned Falls within
an area allocated for housing so whilst
this is a um a residential use in terms
of a care use it unfortunately can't
contribute to our housing Supply it's
not we can't use the the figures of the
bedrooms towards that but National
guidance does allow us to consider
um the the dwellings that are going to
be vacated as a result of residents are
moving into the care home so there is a
calculation that we can use for
assessing this and that's looking at
basing it on 1.55 people equals one unit
of accommodation that's been made
available back into the housing market
and we can consider we can use that
contribution towards our housing
provision
so this application covers 20 of the
housing allocation site the overall
housing allocation is allocated for 80
units so proportionately we would be
looking to try and Achieve 16
residential units within this portion of
the site
so in terms of the actual dwellings that
theoretically would be freed up from
residents moving into this Care Home
there would be approximately 43 units of
accommodation freed up that could
potentially go back
um onto the into the housing market and
contribute towards our figures
not all of these will necessarily be
local and we did look at whether we
could restrict the occupation of the
buildings so that all that the initial
occupiers would all be local
um but unfortunately the applicant is
not keen to have such a restriction it
feels that there could be viability
concerns and and concerns with moral
concerns because I'd rather look at the
need based assessment of future
occupiers rather than their location and
therefore they're not keen to to accept
such a condition but what we would need
is only only 37 of the future occupiers
of the care home would need to come from
the thanet area to result in a number
enough houses freed up that would be
equivalent to the 16 units that we would
need to achieve on sites who achieve the
proportion for this allocation
so um we feel that it's reasonable to
assume that at least 37 are likely to be
local because it is probably the case
that majority would actually be local
and therefore we feel that there is a
whilst it's not technically in line with
the policy there's
um
enough evidence here in terms of the
national guidance and the way it allows
us to work this out to assume that there
would be enough residential units
provided that will contribute towards
our um
local housing provision and need so
therefore it is considered to be an
acceptable departure to that policy on
that basis
in terms of the employment provision so
the employment policy restricts
um the use of the site to the uses I've
mentioned so office
um light industrial and storage
um uses but it does give a the ability
to look at alternative uses if a number
of criteria are met this includes the
marketing of the site and this has taken
place with requested additional
information through the application
initially only six months of marketing
information was submitted but upon going
back to the agent and asking for
additional information we've actually
found that there has been a lot more
marketing that has taken place and
obviously the fact the site's been
vacant for 20 years there would have
been a lot of marketing over that time
but we do have evidence now of at least
21 months of marketing and there's been
no one that's come forward for an
employment use of this site now one of
these reasons could be the actual
um
the actual site that's remaining so
following the deallocation of part of
this site so this this area that is all
in red which is the application site
originally fell part of the employment
site and
um with the 1999 consent all of this
would have you would have had access
from this point here and there would
have been the four employment units
constructed by the de-aducation of this
area there's now no direct vehicular
access to the actual employment site so
if this area were developed for housing
theoretically then there would be this
area in theory would be landlocked
unless they actually applied for a new
vehicle access into the site so there
are quite a few restraints with the
retention of this this site for
employment use there's also limited
space around it
um for trying to get the parking for If
This Were retained as employment use
again they'd have to come in and
actually apply for alternative use
because of the condition restriction and
the reason that policy have looked to
deallocate this area from employment
uses to to do with the proximity to
Residential Properties so this area is
still quite close to the Residential
Properties so again in future employment
use here could still have some impact on
residential so again in terms of this
being a potential future employment use
it's quite limited and that has been
shown by the fact it has been vacant so
long
so local plans have been consulted with
the application they are they have
raised an objection to it on the basis
that it would result in the loss of
employment land and and this would
reduce our employment land Supply
um
but given the fact that there there will
be some employment um generated by the
site through the care home use there
would be 50
who I think is um uh people that were
being full-time equivalent people
employed by the care home whilst that's
not in the type of employment use we're
looking to achieve on this site it would
still have some economic benefits from
that
um and also given the fact that they
have achieved they have provided the
market evidence to show that there's no
um interest in the sign coming forward
and the site restraints of the lack of
access and the proximity of the
allocated
um
housing to this around the site it is
felt that it is reasonable to consider
this as an acceptable departure to the
policy especially given the need for
um a care home which is supported by KCC
and it's also supported by policy ho 18
which does support accommodation for
those in
um in in need of care support
so on balance it is considered that this
the scheme does result in acceptable
departure to both of those policies on
the grounds that we will be achieving
um social and economic benefits from the
development
um and therefore it is recommended for
approval thank you
thank you very much Gemma I move the
officer's recommendation is adopted Vice
chair please second oh second there Joe
thank you coach common cook members
Thank You by and large I support the
intended use of the Land There are some
things that do concern me I do agree
that there is
um that probably is not adequate parking
I think the bin store looks too small
and I'm a little uncertain about some of
the figures around the housing element
on the grounds that most Care Homes cost
more than the KCC standard amount that
is paid and we live in a very deprived
area where most people cannot afford to
pay care home fees so I can understand
why they don't want a limitation on
local residents being in occupation
um
and I think it's not just a case of
freeing up residential places but also
freeing up NHS bed blocking which is a
major issue so I just want to throw
those thoughts out there rather than
specific questions but I think the bin
store is too small and I think the
parking is inadequate
um oh and the bus
um there is a the loop does go into
Tesco's but it's not really a direct
walking route from there so it's
probably a good 10 minute walk from
Tesco's from the loot which so there is
a is a bus route
not great so thrown them out
thank you councilor Garner
thank you yeah um
do I mean I I don't uh I welcome there
being a new Care Home Care Home for
something we do do need in the area so
I'm not against having a care home built
here on principle
um my main concern here is the one
that's been mentioned by the local
resident and by councilor Crittenden and
it is parking
and I think that
I've I've already got a bit of an issue
I've got an issue with KCC highways I
think it's not the first time that we've
been
let down by their recommendations and
I'll tell you why in this particular
incident
I mean I'm the local wall councilor
and I did I speak to residents on the
Wimpy estate quite regularly
especially a number of residents on the
silvers and on on the Northwood Road
who
struggle with the amount of parking on
the Junctions and along that road which
are causing dangerous dangerous access
to the estate
I know the police are aware of this and
the police
are patrolling the area more to try and
stop people doing it
TDC parking enforcement visit the site
quite regularly to try and catch people
parking in appropriately at Junctions
and
I don't believe any of that has been
taken into consideration by KCC highways
when they've said that the parking on
site is adequate they've just
by the look of it looked at looked at
the drawings looked at that and have not
taken any consideration about what's
going on outside the site and I know it
makes it very difficult for us because
KCC Airways have said everything's all
right so it's very difficult for us to
do anything about it but on this
occasion
but I believe KCC highways have let us
down in their report because I haven't
taken all factors into consideration and
they've let the local residents down by
doing doing the same and it becomes very
difficult for us to um talk about it and
and raise objections about it and I
think that's something that I'm just
Keen to make that noted
um I'm in the care home itself looks
looks um looks like a good Karen to me
but it needs more parking and I would
there were just a couple of unrelated to
parking issues I'd like to ask as well
as was mentioned that is a housing site
and I know there are
one one of the applications for housing
will be familiar with because it was at
the top of Fair Lawn Road that's been
before us a couple of times that's for
sure for houses there's another
application just the other side of the
border of that
for a number of other houses as well so
I just wanted to ask if if the perimeter
of that site the care home site is
um shall I say inaccessible from those
from those new houses that are going to
be built I.E is there going to be a
footpath entrance from the new houses
when they'll be built or will that just
be totally encased and I'm one of the
reasons I'm saying that is because when
the new houses are built some of the
people who might like to visit this will
be looking to park there when they can't
park on the Wimpy estate it'll make it
more difficult for them to access the
site
Emma
thank you um
with the the footpath connection so
there's no footpath connections from
this site to the surrounding area other
than through the um the new access onto
Northwood Road
um in terms of actual parking Provisions
so there we've got at the back of the
local plan we've got the
um our parking standards and the parking
standards State how many parking spaces
are required for different types of uses
so for this use there would be the need
for one parking space per six bedrooms
and one
parking space
to staff
um so the 66 bedrooms so that means
there would be a need for 11 spaces for
residents so that covers the Vista
parking and then in terms of the staff
looking through whilst we've said
there's 52 or 54 staff in total that
they're on a roto so in terms of actual
how many would be there at any one time
the statement submitted
um states that there would be around 24
staff there at any one time so that
would result in the need for 12 parking
spaces so we're looking at um a maximum
need of 23 parking spaces because it's
maximum standards and they're providing
25 so in terms of actual parking
provision it'll be very difficult for us
to justify any refusal and parking
provision on the grounds that they meet
and exceed maximum parking standards are
set out within the local plan
thank you um councilor harp
thank you
um I grew by other councilors as well
with Garden parking I know there's
enough but um my other
um comment of course on this is Emma
very kindly showed us pictures of that
building in comparison to the
neighboring property which was an
industrial property with regards to
height but not with regards to housing
opposite or houses to the left
um what is the height difference between
those please
okay new Ella
they are mainly two stories
um
there are some bungalows in the road as
well
so sorry I haven't really got very good
photo of the residents so you can see
here that's a two-story
um neighboring property
um opposite the site on the left-hand
side here there are some
um Chalet style Bungalows
um there aren't anything there's nothing
exceeding to stories in height in terms
of the Residential Properties because
opposite is the wimpiest state where
again they're all two-story there so
um obviously this is proposing a
two-story building so the actual height
of this building is is basically in
keeping with the general character of
the air which is mainly two-story in
height and then it's just the the
commercial well this building on the
corner Northwood court that is the three
stories and the build is beyond that
start becoming larger so in terms of
this building whilst it's larger what is
large
um the two-story height means it's quite
a good transition building between the
much the larger taller buildings and
then the smaller residential buildings
but it's a similar height to those
thank you I'm back on that Jay so how
much taller than the the Residential
Properties will that be as in will it be
30 feet higher 20 feet higher 10 feet
high
um because it's quite considerable
really
so I just clicked back through to this
plan so this plan attempted to show the
level difference
um so this is the proposed Street Scene
so the Residential Properties on the
left hand side of this and then this is
the scheme here so in terms of the ridge
height of the building the proposed
building
it shouldn't exceed the ridge height of
the Residential Properties although I'm
not sure how you know how I don't know
how accurate this plan is it it's not
forming part of the approved plan it's
an initiative plan showing the
scale of the building in relation to
neighboring properties but
I'm not sure I mean the only reason I
asked that chair sorry to make a point
is that when we have that one on the um
Ramsgate Road Margate we agreed property
so it wouldn't be that much more
impressive or over the top of the local
properties and the one opposite the car
wash they are huge and so they do stand
out like a sore thumb so they are very
very high and what I don't want to do is
approve a building that's going to be so
out of keeping with the rest of the area
that it's it's just not right sorry
I think councilor Auburn
yes thank you chair um just to go back
on Council Hearts Point first uh I mean
that is to be set back
from the road so it's not going to have
uh an over impact on the area on on
immediatry of the area the design is
good we need we need the nursing home
the care home uh it creates employment
um of course if we go back to the
parking scene you know wherever you
wherever you live parking's a problem
and I'm sure I'm sure that my green
colleagues here wouldn't want any more
concrete and tarmac in that in that site
over the grass
um so I think that's fine chair and I'm
happy to to go along with the app with
the recommendation thank you uh thank
you councilman Council bayford
thank you Joe yes iaco counselor
Auburn's comments I think it's excellent
use of land I think it's well designed
and I totally agree about the parking um
unfortunately having as much parking as
we would like everywhere we go is a
luxury we can't we can't have these days
we're anywhere in the country
um but first of all I thought it sounded
quite short but when thinking about it
not everybody is going to want the
spaces at the same time there isn't
aren't going to be many residents that
need parking and I don't think we we can
refuse on those grounds anyway I think
we've had a chance so I'm happy to
support the application
thank you councilor Beaufort right I
can't see any other speakers uh
yes sir and we would like to come back
Emma sorry I just wanted to come back
just to confirm the hike because I have
now the measurements in case it's of use
to you so
um looking at this front elevation to
ease level it's 5.2 meters
um the absolute maximum height so that
so it's this Ridge height right in the
middle of the building it's
um 9 9.5 meters and the majority of it
is 8.5 so it is quite low in terms of
the Ridge High and as I said in the
presentation this is because of the fact
that the building's been designed
um with sort of Wide building at the
front and then a gap and then a
whiteboard at the back so it's enabled
the roof to be quite low because it's
not a very deep build in those two
elements
uh thanks for that time up right members
I'm going to put this to you for those
in favor please show
those against
one abstentions
no extensions that has been carried
thank you members
and I hope the applicant has noted
because you've got your places in the
care home in the future members
we were thinking to you chair really I
thought you might be
thank you
thank you members um agenda item 4C
which is a 20 Saint Mary's Avenue in
Margate uh speaking against this
application is Miss
putridge
thank you thank you again you have three
minutes thank you very much good evening
everybody
um part of the proposed planning
application seeks to build at the front
of the house a first floor extension on
top of the existing ground floor room
Southeast facing side to be used as a
walk-in wardrobe and ensuite
the doubling in height of this wall will
result in a significant loss of natural
light to all our rooms
facing this looming wall should it be
approved namely our kitchen downstairs
hallway upstairs Landing separate toilet
and bathroom
my partner I feel that this part of the
planning application will have a
significant impact on the quality of
life which we currently enjoy in our
home and we ask that it be taken into
consideration indeed we would kindly
request a site visit so that you can
gain a better understanding of the
impact of the proposed doubling of the
Wall height
the case officer report submits that
there may be some reduction in light
an Outlook to these windows but goes on
to say that they do not serve main
habitable rooms where we disagree these
rooms particularly the kitchen are used
all the time well mostly all almost all
the time
um what what is more why should we have
to turn on electric light during daytime
in order to move from one room to
another I would go so fast to say that
the building of a walking wardrobe and
ensuite is not as important as our loss
of natural light
notwithstanding the above has the
developer undertaken a bre assessment if
not we would ask that the council defer
its decision until this has been made
our second concern relates to the
overall increase in size of the property
we do not feel it's in keeping with the
size of the other properties in the road
but is disproportionately large
need it neither is the design in keeping
with the character the other Bungalows
and the houses in the road
the case officer States in her comments
that the property has a fairly unique
appearance within the street and does
not directly relate our architecturally
style to the neighboring two-story
buildings or to single story dwellings
we wholly agree with this finding is
this not a reason enough to deny the
application in its present form
thank you uh thank you I now ask the
officer I'm actually to outline this
application
thank you chairman um so this is the
application site outline in red here the
Saint Mary's Avenue on the right hand
side
um we've got the church opposite the
site and the south is Mill Mead Road and
to the left hand side of the screen is
milmead Gardens
so this is the application site here
um you can see it's a detached property
it has a garage to the left hand or
right hand side but you can see on the
left-hand side of this picture and a
conservative to the rear and both are
being demolished through this proposal
and new extensions built in their place
can see that the neighbor properties are
also all detached properties and this is
a view from the rear so again this is
the application property here this is a
rear view of that property
and this is now from street level so
looking at the application site from the
street so you can see it's
got quite a low ease level with a small
Gable project projection on the
left-hand side this is their garage so
the application site boundary runs up to
the right hand side of the garage and
the garage is currently on the boundary
of the site
and then a further away view so in terms
of this property it's
um it's quite different in design to
both neighboring properties so on the
left hand side you can see the two-story
houses
and that's the same to the the
properties that keep going to the
left-hand side and then to the right
hand side they become Bungalows and
that's the same down the street as well
so this is a property in between a
bungalow and a house and you can see
it's got a um therefore a ridge line
that sort of runs but like extends
between the two different Ridge lines
between the property and of a different
design as well
so again the application property is the
one on the left hand side here again you
see the Bungalows that then extend along
the road and on the left hand side so
again the application properties to
build on the right hand side and then
you can see the two-story houses on the
left of
um the the photo here
and then a slightly wider view so the
application site is this one here so
it's it's also set back further than the
neighboring property so whilst they do
have a Gable projection here the front
elevation of that Gable projection is in
line with the front elevation of
neighboring properties and then the main
bulk of the building is set back behind
and then again the view here so the
application properties on the left hand
side behind these two-story houses and
again you can see opposite the site is
the church and a screen of trees
and then this is taken from the right
hand side looking towards it so again
that is the application property in that
location there so the proposal is for a
first floor extension over that Gable
projection a two-story extension in this
location here which then is of a similar
design to what results from that first
for extension the demolition of the
garage that's currently on the boundary
and the direction of a single story
extension in this location here and the
demolition of the rear conservatory and
the erection of a single story extension
in this location here
so this is the existing front elevation
and this is now the proposed so you can
see the dotted red line is showing the
height of the existing roof of that
Gable projection and there's an increase
of 2.3 meters up to the new ease level
of this Gable projection and that will
extend above it the Ridgeline of the
building is not increasing so this
Remains the Same so the only changes are
the the direction of this first edition
above the single story and then this is
a two-story front projection which will
then match the design of the left hand
side then on the right hand side here
you can see the garage has gone so the
garage is in the place of the dotted red
line which was up to the boundary this
extension now extends away from the
boundaries there's now a 0.9 meter Gap
to the boundary with a parapet roof and
again a design with Windows and
materials that will match the the main
building
um this is the
um South face in no east facing
elevation sorry it says it's a west
facing Innovation sorry I get it right
west facing Innovation
um so this is
um so this is the existing Gable
projection to the front so the road is
to the front or to the left-hand side of
this slide this is the existing Garage
in this location here and this is the
concert the existing conservatory and
then this is the proposed elevation so
this is now the two-story front
projection in this location here and
this here is the sting single story side
extension and then you can see the rear
extension at single story level
projecting out in this location here
and this is the rear elevation as
existing with the conservatory and the
garage and this is now it proposed so
again it's all very similar design
um parapet roof the whole way round
um the original when it originally was
submitted it did propose a balcony area
or roof Terrace in this location here so
there was many concerns from residents
regarding overlooking from this space so
plans have been amended to remove the
roof Terrace and this is now shown as a
um about a balcony with French doors so
there's not considered to be any any
direct overlooking from this this uh um
this opening now
and then this is the view
um so to the neighbor to the left hand
side
um again this is the existing front
Gable the rear conservatory and then the
proposal so you can see the first floor
um front extension in this location here
and again you can see the rear extension
in this location here
so in terms of openings within the side
elevation at first floor level there's
no additional openings it's just the
existing openings that remain the same
so there's no overlooking from first or
level directly to any neighbors and at
ground floor level there are a few
additional openings but again these
would be at ground floor level and
behind any any boundary treatment
so this is the existing floor plan at
ground floor level
and this is the proposed so again this
is ground floor projection here to the
front of the property again the side
extension so this extension set back
um
3.6 meters from the front elevation
um not 0.9 meters from that boundary and
then to the rear this extension here
which replaces the conservatory which is
of a similar of the same depth so this
extension to the rear is four meters
deep
and you can see that this is also set
off the The Boundary by around um 0.9
meters as well
and then this is existing first floor
plan and then the proposed first for
plan so you can see the projection here
of the first floor front extension and
the projection here of the two-story
um front projection and then there's
also a small infill projection at first
floor level as well between the two but
you can see that's quite a setback from
those Gables
and then existing roof plan and proposed
roof plan so
um the main issues are the impact on the
character appearance of the area and the
impact on living conditions so in terms
of the impacts on living conditions just
looking at this proposed block plan and
you can see there's quite quite a
distance to both neighboring properties
from the proposed extensions
so to the so to number 18 which is in
this location here
um the two-story front extensions
located
5.4 meters from number 18
um and uh there's a distance of 7.8
meters from the first extension to
number 22.
um this plan shows that with in terms of
looking at the path of the sun the sun
will be passing around on the starting
from the East here going around to the
South here so in terms of the impact on
22 there should be no impact in terms of
light because the extension is is to the
south of that property to the north of
that property and then in terms of the
impact on number 18 again you can see
the distance obviously this is only
single story at this level here so the
nearest two-story is is quite a distance
from that property and in terms of the
the the distance the path of the sun
it's not considered that would have a
significant impact on that property
um just just heading back I'll just
sorry show you the photos again of the
of the neighboring properties and and
openings so
you can see sorry I'll just get to the
right one so this is
um
number uh 22 on the left hand side so
again the application properties here so
you can see they do have openings within
the side elevation here so these
um are because I'll serve in kitchen and
hallway Windows Landing Windows toilets
bathroom windows so all all of these
windows and the rooms that they serve
are all considered to be non-habitable
rooms and therefore the impact on these
windows again given the distance and the
fact the non-hampton rooms it's not
considered that the increase in height
of this front extension would
significantly impact on on light or
Outlet to that property and similarly
for the
um Bungalow so number 18 you can see
they also have some openings within that
side elevation and you can see there's a
door and a window so I believe they are
server again a kitchen area and and
you've got the door that says that there
as well but again given that distance
the fact that there's garage that's
currently on the boundary and the
proposed extension is set away from the
boundaries so it's actually increasing
the distance from the development to The
Bungalow so the the impact on light and
Outlook from the proposed side extension
is actually considered to potentially
proof for those windows and openings
within that side elevation the side
extension is slightly deeper than the
existing garage but again given the
distance it's an oxidative that would
have a really harmful impact
in terms of the design
um
flipping flicking back to here so it
it's it's providing a double Gable
frontish design which is is different to
other properties in the street but as
you can see from the photos there's
already a building that isn't similar in
design to other properties in the street
um The Ridge line is an increase in so
in terms of where it sits within the
street actually I do have the street
Innovation sorry I'll just show you that
because that's very useful
um
here you go so in terms of the street
elevation you can see that the ridge
line isn't increasing it still will
remain below the ridge line of the
two-story property in terms of the ease
level whilst the first extension and
two-story extension projecting forward
the easy level of both of these again
fall below the two-story building so it
still works quite well as a transition
building between a two-story building
and The Bungalow in terms of the
materials they are proposing some render
and there is some evidence of render on
other properties in the street although
they are mainly brick but at ground
floor level all of this will be red
brick in keeping with the neighbors
um in terms of the actual front
projection these the front Gables will
follow the front building line of the
neighboring properties so there's no
concern regarding how it it sits in
terms of the street elevation in terms
of projection because there would be the
same depth set back from the road
so it's considered that whilst
um
it is you know a different design it's
not significantly out of character of
the area or the fact that these exist in
the existing design differs to
surrounding properties it's not so that
this would be harmful to the character
appearance of the area and given the
distances two neighbors the impact on
the neighboring that means he is
considered to be acceptable so it is
recommended for approval thank you uh
thank you Emma I recommendous
recommendation is adopted the vice chair
please second
oh second nature thank you Council
Corbin cook members
any comments
not a hand
well they thank you very much but
therefore I put this to you those in
favor of this application please show
the hand
those against
any abstentions
that unanimous thank you very much
and carried thank you and myself yep
thank you members
uh moving on and we'll get permission
for people if they want to put their
coats on
um you can
quite the Opposites what we used to um a
gender item for d
uh which is 31 Southward Road Ramsgate
speaking in favor of this applications
is Mr gillens Mr Jones are you there
you have three minutes
okay thank you good evening members
um this application is for a side porch
on the on the main house the rear
kitchen extension on the main house and
a double garage at the end of the garden
um this was originally approved by
planning in March 2018 but due to
circumstances cover I had a cancer
diagnosis and so on it's put me back
we've had to reapply
because the original application timed
out
the the rear extension on the house and
the porch replacement porch are exactly
the same as was approved in March 2018
and just as a point of note the the rear
extension does not protrude back even as
far as the rear extension on my neighbor
at number 33 south of Road and is
contained behind a 2.5 meter high
perimeter wall which runs all the way
around my garden a brick wall so there's
no impact on neighbors or or the general
public walking by
the garage is
largely the same but I made two
important amendments to the plan that
was originally passed
the the architect that submitted the
plan had shown the a symmetrical gable
roof uh which with the ridge running
from north to south
which would have meant that the Gable
land the North End Gable end would have
cast a shadow over the rear neighbor's
Garden which I didn't want
um so I've changed that to an
asymmetrical gable roof with the ridge
running east to west the North Slope
will be about 25 degrees and the South
slope 35 degrees what that does is it
means that with the access alley a meter
wide between me and the rear neighbor
and their two meter high fence
they won't even see the roof so there'll
be no impact on their natural light and
there'd be no impact on their line of
sight
or a feeling of enclosure
um the 35 degree south facing roof also
gives me option later on of fitting
solar panels
the other important amendment I made is
is that in the original plan the
garage wall on the Napleton roadside was
set back from my garden wall
one of the things I wanted to achieve
was easier and safer access to and from
the garage
so I've redrawn it so that the garage
wall is butted up against the Garden
Wall
the purpose of that is that instead of
having to park at right angles the road
I can park almost parallel to the road
now the other issue that might arise
with the rear neighbor is traffic
movements but one thing I'd like to just
um
the existing
um vehicular rights of a long-standing
and um
I've given evidence that even before
1971 there was a garage there and the
local plan map even shows that the
garage standing there I'm also making
improvements to the the end wall to
bring it back from the road to improve
the safety for people
um exiting the alley because there's no
pavement there
so um
um the the the issue of traffic
movements won't change I'm using it
daily now as it is thank you uh thank
you Mr Jones uh write us a plan planning
officer which is Annabelle this time I
think to outline this application
so this is the application site outlined
in red number 31 Salford Road it's a
Salford Road running across the middle
of the slide Napleton Road running north
to south and Bloomsbury excuse me blooms
Road at the top of the slide
so this is the aerial view of the site
so this is number 31 here it's rear
Garden
up here
um this is the western side of the front
of number 31 you can see a porch here
and this is the main bulk of the front
elevation
this is number 31 on the left hand side
of the slide
number 29
South Road on the right hand side and
you're looking down in Appleton Road in
the middle here
so this is number 31 on the left hand
side again so we're looking down on
track looking down Appleton Road
here
um towards Bloomsbury Road at the
at this far end
so this is a view from Napleton Road
this is number 31 here this is the rear
wall uh sidewall that's been talked
about so it's quite a high brick wall
you can see
um there is an existing structure to the
rear of number 31 but this is where the
rear extension will be put in this
location here
laughs
so we're looking again down Appleton
road but this is number 31 the
application site in the here and this is
number 38 Bloomsbury Road
and this is just enough of you of the
end of The Garden of number 31 Salford
Road here the gates are in already in
existence
this is the alleyway that's been talked
about so we've got a boundary wall here
of some two meters in height
the alleyway is a meter in width and
then there's enough of four meters of
garden before you get to the flank well
the rear wall of number 38 Bloomsbury
Road
so essentially there are two parts to
this application
the rear extension and the proposed
garage so we'll look at those in turn
so this is the block plan of the site
this is where the re-extension would sit
and the papers garage as we say to the
rear of the uh the garden
so this is existing rear elevation
and this is the rear elevation as
proposed so you'd see
the extension here and as has been said
this is a similar extension where what's
almost identical to the extensional
proposed and approved in as an
application in 2017 approved in 2018.
so this is the existing East Elevation
and that's the proposed Innovation East
Elevation so you could this would face
onto Appleton Road and you can just see
above the roof the existing wall part of
the top part of the roof of the
extension
this is the west elevation as existing
and the west elevation has proposed you
can just see here the extension
looking at the floor plans
so this is the front of the property
and these are the existing floor plans
so ground floor here
um
first floor here
this is the proposed floor plan so you
can see the extension is here and it's a
kitchen Diner extension and it would
measure some 5.2 meters out from the
existing rear of the property and then
you have an actual area of decking that
is 1.8 meters beyond the rear of most
part of their proposed extension
and you can see on
on the first floor plan that it is
single story and we have a roof just the
roof plan here
so again has as has been mentioned the
previous extent application in 2017
granted the rear extension which is the
same as what's being proposed now
and also a garage
but as as excuse me been explained the
garage is slightly different
now to what was proposed and approved
previously
so this was the previously approved
garage
and you can see it was set in further
back from Napleton road than this the
garage that's now being proposed
so this is what's being proposed now and
as you can see this it is coming further
forward
than what was previously approved closer
to an Appleton Road
this was the East Elevation that you
would see
from Napleton Road it's facing Appleton
Road in 2017. and this is the proposed
of the garage that we're considering
tonight
and the same East Elevation
so looking at the self-elevation of the
proposed garage
and the north elevation
and the west elevation of that garage
so
there have been concerns raised
particularly in relation to Highway
issues
and whether they're appropriate access
and Opera can be achieved from the
garage KCC highways have considered
the proposal and have made a comment on
it even though it is a non-protical
application for them
they are happy with it and raise no
objection on the basis that vehicle
movements are not likely to be limited
there's a roller shutter door proposed
that would not open out onto the highway
and also traffic speeds going along
Napleton Road given its width will be
relatively slow so it is not considered
there will be an impact in terms of
sorry Highway movements or access
or impacts in from the operation and use
of that garage it is also consent have
also been raised that the garage could
be used as a a commercial Workshop or
offer
business use which might need an
unnecessary noise and disturbance that
wouldn't normally be found in a
residential area but given the size of
the garage it's domestic in scale
um it is not considered that it is
likely but we have put a condition on
that does
um only allow the garage to be used for
incidential purposes in relation to the
use of the dwelling and the the garden
as a whole so it is not
um considered there would be an impact
from that
so
given that the officer recommendation is
for one for approval thank you chair uh
thank you very much Annabelle uh once
again our movie officers recommendation
we adopted uh Vice chair please second
oh second nature thank you Council
common cook members
but I've never known that before
so I put it I put this to you members uh
those in favor this application please
show
against
any abstentions
that is unanimous once again thank you
and that will prove yourself thank you
thank you thank you
uh right uh going on to gender item
a06 which is the Outlook Fox for Elaine
Minster
speaking in favor of this application is
Mr Vine
do I see a Mr Vine there
once again Mr Vine good evening and
sorry to keep you waiting but the long
agenda tonight as you gather that you
have three minutes
yeah
I was approached in 2019 by Finn's land
agents referenced my earlier request
some 30 years ago for a small piece of
land to grow extra vegetables at my
Bungalow they offered me a small site
next to my Bungalow in exchange for some
of my Frontage onto Foxwood Lane an
agreement was made and the contract
signed and completed when the agent came
to site to set the boundary I asked
whether I needed change of use he told
me and I quote there is no need
therefore I continue to erect the
boundary fence and proceed to make the
ground ready for planting we have had
three years of crops and I've also
planted some 20 plus trees with regard
to the small cabin this is a slot
together unit positioned on a wooden
deck and is not fixed to it so a
constitute a portable building the
extension to the top of the fence is to
prevent fertilizer pellets hitting us or
the chickens where we are in that
vicinity as they come over the wooden
fence with great velocity
as you can see it's a lightweight frame
with a green mesh which blends in with
the surrounding crops and trees
with regard to the letters of opposition
some of these people knew of my
intentions as I had discussed it with
them and in fact one came to my gate
with a daughter and requested the
contact details of the land agent as
they and their neighbor wanted to
purchase some and after three years now
objects to the sale of the land
as for her comment that the application
is abhorrent I was misled by the land
agent and had no intentions of bypassing
any regulations for planning
requirements
as for house built you know I have no
intentions of building and the plot is
not connected to the highway
in response to the other objections the
lamb was a grass track for the last 10
years there are more animals and insects
now including the Hedgehog who comes
through the hole left in the fence for
that purpose and has made his home under
the cabin there are bird boxes and
feeding station that areas constructed
for bees butterflies and beetles to
overwinter there is also a small
Wildlife Pond for frogs and dragonflies
lastly the fence is not hidden from View
and to say I covertly erected it hoping
no one would see it is beyond belief as
it is in full view of all the properties
the total Hill House and laundry road
for the last three years without coming
in conclusion thank you for allowing me
to offer this deposition for your
consideration uh thank you very much Mr
Vine um I asked the plan officer now
which is back to me and to give his
report please
thank you chair
um the application site is outlined in
red the property uh that this uh this
bit of land is connected to is now the
Outlook which you can see there just to
show you the aerial image of the
property itself so the area that we're
talking about is the one that is on the
right hand side here uh so just having a
look from a 3D view you can see the area
in question
so going into that site so this is in
that section of land you can see the
structure at the end and you can see
some low-level structures
um in the center as well
this is just a view looking back towards
I suppose towards the road but obviously
you can't see the road because of the
amount of planting at the front of the
site which isn't isn't within this site
this land
and this is just showing the single
story structure so it's a small
structure and it's not considered to
have any impact on the countryside due
to its scale
this is the original boundary wall of uh
the property so originally this sort of
faced onto the field
and then this is the now the the new
fence or new newer fence that was
erected a few years ago which faces uh
the field itself
so this is a view looking to the east so
it was literally the fence is behind
um behind the photograph effectively and
then this is looking towards Foxborough
Lane so you can see there's a lot of
planting on Foxborough lane and then
there's a gap where the road is
um and then this is from obviously from
the actual Farmland itself
and then this just turning to the left
there just to show again that amount of
planting you've got there
and this is just again showing that fact
that the the land itself that's been
changed to residential Garden is not
connected to the road so this is the
hedging that's there
so this is a view taken from the west of
the site looking along Foxboro Lane
towards the site so
um you've got the garage of the Outlook
in the center of the site there and then
this is the other side of that boundary
planting
um and then this is a view taken from
Google Street View but from
um November this so this year and you
can see the fence there uh in the
background so the main issues on this is
it is development in the countryside
however it's not considered to result in
the loss or harm to the character of the
countryside or the landscape character
due to its scale
um it is also on agricultural land and
therefore there is a policy e16 which
looks at um loss of loss of best and
most versatile
um
however
given that the loss of the error in
quest in this instance is is so minimal
it's not considered resulting
significant harm to the supply of
agricultural land in the district it
doesn't affect the holding itself and
therefore it's not considered to be
significantly harmful to Warrant refusal
against that particular policy and so on
that basis it is recommended to allow
for the change of use to residential
Garden land thank you chair thank you
then I move the officers recommendation
is adopted with Vice chair please second
or second
councilman cup members
it's three in a row right
those are those in favor
anybody against
absentions
that is obviously unanimous thank you
members that's myself as well thank you
moving on once again
um to
agenda items still for the which is D12
number four York Street in broadstairs
uh speaking in favor of the application
is a Mrs Jody Blythe
if you're there yes
thank you chairman thank you you have
three minutes once again
thank you chairman I represent the
applicant in speaking in support of this
application the site is located within
broadstairs town center and Conservation
Area and within the secondary shopping
Frontage of York Street
The Proposal is to retain the existing
shop use at ground floor and to make an
efficient use of the highly sustainable
sites to deliver a single unit of
residential accommodation in accordance
with local and National policy
requirements that seek to encourage
residential use in town centers
the application before members has been
designed in direct response to feedback
received from local residents and
offices including heritage heritage
advice in respect of an earlier planning
application for the development of this
site
the design has moved away from the more
contemporary approach initially proposed
and the scheme has addressed the
concerns raised by the conservation area
in consideration of the previous scheme
which related to a confusing and complex
reform and an
unacceptable scale of development
an important design aspect is that the
first floor element of The Proposal is
substantially set back from the ground
floor
in a similar manner to that of the
adjoining properties such that the shop
front will continue to provide the main
focus of the site within the Town Center
the applicant is happy to accept a
condition to prevent the use of the
first floor area to the front of the
site as a Terrace as suggested by
officers
the Flint wall on the west side of the
yard shall be retained
mindful of the relationship of the site
to neighboring properties the proposed
living space is largely confined to the
ground floor with only an ensuite
bedroom at first floor level
Windows serving the first floor bedroom
are full are facing forwards into York
Street and there is a single window
facing to the rear
the ground floor living space benefits
from an internal Courtyard providing a
source of natural light to the main
rooms
this Arrangement will provide future
residents with a good level of amenities
and meet all relevant technical
standards
this development has been found to be
acceptable in all other respects and
this is reflected in your office's
recommendation to approve planning
permission
we feel that you're proposed we feel
that the proposal now meets with
relevant policy provisions and we hope
that you can lend your support to the
proposal proposal thank you for
listening thank you very much
speaking under Council procedure 20.1 is
a counselor Ruth Bailey Castle Bailey
thank you good evening I'm speaking
against this application on behalf of
residents in my ward who cannot be here
tonight
this proposed new dwelling will be cited
in what is currently a work yard within
a wider Conservation Area it would be
shoehorned between residential and
Commercial businesses which surround the
site block of residential apartments on
one side an existing shop to the front
and to the rear
um and the on the opposite side several
businesses the rear of several
businesses
including restaurants and a shoe
repairing slash key cutting business
the conservation officer did remove her
initial overall objection but she still
cites residual concerns which affect
this historic environment
namely that the designer materials are
still somewhat contemporary that that
the structure as mentioned could be used
as a roof Terrace and that the Flint
wall which is considered to contribute
well to the character and appearance of
the surrounding Conservation Area should
be retained
as you heard the concern regarding the
potential for roof Terrace has been
conditioned through a fixed window but
the materials and design remain the same
with regard to the Flint wall the flank
wall of the new development appears to
be built right up to the boundary line
so it will defectively conceal and
subsume the length of the wall leaving
only a very small area of Flint left
exposed to the rear
the concern of the neighboring
Apartments is that there would be a
reduction in light and a sense of
enclosure the separating wall will more
than double in height with the second
story of the proposed building being
even higher and this new structure would
also alter the historic Street Scene
on the opposite side there would be a
reduction in natural light to the
workshop at the rear of the shoe repair
business who depends on light for his
work
also with regard to the living
conditions of any future inhabitants of
this proposed dwelling the only view I
can see of any kind from the ground
floor living space would appear to be
brick walls hardly conducive to good
health and well-being
apart from a very small courtyard
there's barely any outdoor amenity space
also the window of the Cobblers Workshop
is adjacent to this proposed Courtyard
and the noise from his machinery would
be very noticeable especially in the
summer months when the windows are open
there are also flus and extractor fans
at the rear of the two restaurants which
back onto this property which could
cause odor and Noise
and finally while realizing that town
center developments are not required to
provide off-street parking this
development is cited on a busy narrow
one-way road with double yellow lines in
the Conservation Area
and any removals deliveries utilities
servicing this premises would block the
road in addition a valuable existing
parking space to the front will be lost
to storage for bins and a bike shed for
these reasons I would ask members to
consider this application carefully and
even suggest that site visit might be
helpful to appreciate how crammed this
development is and to assess the
relationship to the surrounding
residential and commercial buildings and
to the overall Street Scene thank you uh
thank you very much councilor Bailey
um the officer now will outline the
report which I believe is Annabelle
so this is the occasion site outlined in
red
we have Serene portraits that are
apartment block on the left hand side
here
and Commercial properties with some
residential above turning the corner
into Charlotte Street
and so as has been mentioned it the site
is in the broadstairs Town Center within
the Conservation Area
so this scenario view of the site so the
site is this area here
um that's the apartment block we've
looked at previously
so just looking at some photographs of
the site so this is the application side
here the front view of it facing onto
York street it's got distinctive sort of
green Frontage which might be helpful
when you sort of look at some of the
other photographs to get your bearings
um
so looking
again this is the front of the
application site the single story
elements that's on the site now so it's
got the green
um
Frontage there and the green to the top
of the roof here this is the block of
flats and this is a joining commercial
property
also facing York street with a two-story
element or first floor elements set back
from York Street
again this is a better view of the
adjoining commercial building with its
two-story element there the flats
um just poking out here and some Upper
Floor accommodation
here on other properties as you start to
go around into Charlotte Street
so this is the rear of the site
this is the actual
um single story element that's on the
site there you can see the distinctive
sort of green part to the roof here
you can see this is the two of the first
floor element that's above the
commercial property that joins the site
this is Serene Court here
and this is a area Flint wall I've
that's been talked about and this is a
shoe repair business
just in this building here
so again another view of the back of the
site so you can just see this is the
rear of the single story element on the
site and this is the first floor above
the adjoining commercial property and we
have some other
back views of first floor and
second floor development above
but not in the site and again with
moving further around so we've got that
first floor element here and some other
higher
um development it on
above properties where properties facing
Charlotte Street so this is the shoe
repair business that's been talked about
so it is a commercial building
and
and there is still a white right-of-way
which we'll see later on that does
provide access to this site
but it would be impacted
by the proposed development but it is
born in mind that it is commercial not
residential and it would be used at
certain hours and not occupied uh 24
hours a day
so just giving enough a view of the
um the application site so it's here you
can see the flat building here
and you can see the
upper floors here
and you can see the slight setback but
we'll look at that later from the
parapet and the front facing York Road
so this is the existing block plan
so this is the single story element that
we've looked at and the rest of the site
what we've looked at is open up
presently
so this is the pose block plan so you
can see
you've got this light colored gray area
is new development
so this is the existing ground floor so
the single story element that we've seen
here
and this is a proposed ground floor so
we've still got the existing single
story bit here
and then we have this single story
extension running off into the yard that
we've just looked at and this is the
internal Courtyard that's been referred
to so
it would have an element of
amenity space within the site
so this is the existing well essentially
roof plan because we're only looking at
single story existing development here
and this is the
proposed first floor so this is the only
actual first floor accommodation that's
being proposed so that is the bedroom
and the ensuite that's been mentioned
so this is as you can see it's set back
from the front of York Road and this is
the green roof of of the um proposed
single story extension and this is the
internal Courtyard
so looking at some elevations now so
this is the front of the
existing front elevation facing York
Road
and this is a proposed
elevation so you can see the existing
building here this is the first floor
element that we saw
so again this is the
side elevation
so you can see it as existing so this is
York Road here
and this is the
proposed same elevation so this is the
existing single story building that
would be retained in commercial use this
is the first floor element here
and the rest is a single story
um
extension that comes
further along the side
so this is the elevation you can see the
block of flats behind this is how it is
as existing and this is the proposed
with the block of flats behind so the
existing single story element
the first floor element that's being
proposed which is set back from York
Street and then we go off and look at
essentially this is the courtyard bit
and the internal
area of the ground floor as proposed
and this is the rear so you can see this
is the existing single story building
that we have on site
and this would be the proposed rear that
you would see so again you can see the
courtyard the two-story element and this
is the single story element that
protrudes further back into the site
and we just have a look at some
perspectives that have been shown so
here we have the existing single story
element the and the block of Flats on
the left hand side here
and this is it has proposed so you can
see it retains that strong single story
element facing York Street the two-story
element is set back and then you can
just see the single story element
running off there
enough a perspective again looking at
the
existing relationship between
the single story element that's on site
now and the block of flats and this is
as proposed so you have the block of
flats here you can see the setback of
the first floor element here so there is
a gap there and the relationship between
the build the proposal and the block of
flats is considered to be acceptable
um this is actually a view of a
perspective view anyway of what we might
expect to see from if you were looking
at one of the windows of the block of
flats here on the side so you'd see the
green roof
you'd see the courtyard
poking out and you'd see the two-story
element but it's not but you can see the
distance between the two
developments and you can also see that
it would be set back from
um York Street so it's not considered
that there is an impact on those Flats
that would be significantly harmful to
recommend refusal on that basis
we have again another perspective view
here where you can see
the single story element the first floor
element and the neighboring
a relationship with the first floor
element here which is also set back
so to summarize members it is noted that
the site is in the urban confines and
the commercial use will remain on site
so there is no in principle objection to
this proposal
um there is considered to be an
acceptable relationship between the
proposed development existing buildings
and that does include that the shoe
repair building
um that is
has a right-of-way to the rear of this
property and that right of way will be
retained and there may be some loss of
light to the windows that serve that
building but has as had been mentioned
it is a commercial building it is not
residential so they're not habitable
rooms and it is expected that
um
the use of that building would only be
at certain times a day and not being
used 24 hours a day so it's not
considered the impact on that building
would be significantly harmful
there is not considered to be an adverse
impact on the character and appearance
of the conservation area and although it
is relatively contemporary in nature
and the conservation office not
conservation officer is not now raising
any objection to it but just merely
pointing out it is fairly contemporary
in nature
excuse me the proposed development does
meet the required space standards and
would is considered to provide a good
standard accommodation for future
occupiers
um yes the amenity space that is
provided on site might be relatively
small but it is better than what's found
on many Town Center sites
um where often no a residential amenity
space is provided at all given the
constraints of the site
um it is sustainable a very sustainable
location in the town center and it is
not considered there is a requirement
for any off street parking to be
provided
there is however a requirement for the
Sam contribution
and it is therefore recommended that the
application is deferred and dedicated
for approval
subject to the safeguarding conditions
and the submission of an undertaking for
the Sam contribution to be provided
thank you thank you Annabelle I moved
the officer's recommendation is adopted
as you heard by share please second
members
customer
yes thank you chair
um these perspectives that we're looking
between the block of flats are they
actually scaled correctly because I I
know that area and it doesn't look that
wide when I go past it
um so I'm just wondering whether the
actual gaps have just been the poetic
license of an architect to make
something look wider than it actually is
um I think also that
um well I don't like it at all it's
cramming it's putting something shoehorn
a building into a small area and I don't
think it's appropriate so on that basis
I don't think I'd be supporting this
application
I think about some more Council Ghana
thank you uh yeah I do
partly Echo councilor Moore's
statement it is
it is um
it's almost like a case study in
cramming into a smaller Pace space as
possible with uh with the yard almost
oh it's very minimal you could probably
get a chair in there to sit outside it
is very
cramming
um
I was interested to look at the Outlook
from the block of flats
um and yeah if you're in the third floor
a third floor flat looking out of there
then it doesn't particularly obscure
your view
if however you're in the ground one of
the ground floor Flats it does
so I think if the Outlook had been from
the ground floor rather than from the
third floor as it was it would have been
slightly different
um and I'm a little bit confused about I
heard
mentioned that the Flint wall
was being kept but I didn't see quite
how that is
being kept there there wasn't any view
of it in any of the drawings and yeah
there is one other one other comment
um he talked about obscuring the light
of the business in Charlotte Street and
Peter's shoe repairs which I'm familiar
with because I have had shoes repaired
in there and the light his Workshop
light will be impaired so I it will have
to I switch his lights on a lot more
regularly to do his work or I might have
to look
for another shoe repairs thank you very
much thank you for that cancer Garner
before I've been Council printed in in
thanks just to come back on a couple of
the points that have been raised so one
on the perspective back to council most
put
um you know they are they are
perspectives we're not considering those
we're considering these floor plans so
indeed there's there's going to be an
element of interpretation I think in
terms of this floor plan you can see
what you've got on the the left hand
side of the green line is the gap
between Serene court and this site so
there is a vehicular access with a gate
and then a sort of width of a vehicle
for about three meters running down the
side of serene Court
um so there is there is a gap there
um but again I think you have to take
the perspectives as always with a slight
pinch of sold because they are just that
I think they're useful and just in terms
of understanding the different roof
forms you've got there and the fact that
the element is set back
um just to pick up a couple of points um
one um this is a one bed unit
um therefore there's no requirement for
any external immunity space under policy
gio4 so if it was a two bed unit then
you'd have to provide some amenity space
but there is no minimum standard to me
you see space but it's a one bed unit
um in terms of the concerns about Serene
Court
um in terms of
um the the ground floor there are no
ground floor Windows as such facing this
site it's it's the access it's the
actual entrance to the flat and then
it's a literally a vehicle route to a
driveway so it's the the first lot of
accommodation is set up but it's not
quite two-story
um I may if if if members would permit
me I'll show you on street view
um I'm probably going to break the
system by doing this but let's just see
if it works so there you go there's
there's the just the view down the side
of serene court so these aren't quite
second floor Windows because you can see
it slightly seems like a reduced height
but we don't have a major concern in
terms of the impact because you're
looking over what is a single story
structure that's one of the issues with
the previous application which I'm
afraid we don't have the plans of to
show you members because it's not under
consideration but that had a two-story
element that went further back than what
we currently have and that's one of the
reasons why it was removed because of
the impact on Serene Court can I stop
presenting and then will it show you
what was there
um that's not the proposal just to make
it very clear
um brought his Harbor in in terms of the
last thing for me and then I'll I'll
pass to Annabelle to talk about the film
more
um in terms of light to a commercial
premises that's not enshrined as
something that we can protect under
planning policy if it was living
conditions Residential Properties then
it is something
um but um again that I think the issue
is
you technically again it's not
necessarily a a
uh it is a fallback that obviously
someone could build a two meter high
wall in front of that to you know
Safeguard their land obviously at the
moment the boundary is clearly the
building and that I appreciate it
creates a bit of an interesting aspect
sometimes when you've got side windows
that are literally facing into a site
which could result though you know in
putting a a two meter high wall allowing
for the access that animals mentioned
straight in front of those windows at
the moment in terms of light but um I'll
pass down about the Flint aspect
yeah the members this Photograph May Aid
you in looking at the Flint wall it is
this bit of War as I understand that
it's being talked about
it
yeah
yeah
sorry
yeah that will
um have some building and not be readily
viewable from
um within the conservation area but it
is not actually that visible from the
conservation area The Wider conservation
as it currently stands because it is to
the rear of
this site so it is shielded from the
most views of the conservation area by
the existing single story building and
the access road we just looked at so
it is not considered that
it actually would be its loss given its
limited visibility at the present time
would be significantly enough to Warrant
a recommendation for refusal on this
application
uh thank you Council crinton
thank you
um one part of my question was about the
the Flint wall um the other part of what
I wanted to say was I'm actually quite a
fan of modern architecture I like what's
behind the frontage but I think the
frontage is maintaining the historic
element so it kind of meets both of
those and
it is a little bit crammed in but
broadly I think actually on on balance I
I like it
thank you uh councilor Hart
hey I must admit I I totally agree with
cancer screening I think it's a very
inventive use of space it's a derelict
site at the back of that shop and I
think to use it and make it into a
habitable space is absolutely superb I
think putting a green roof on it is
better than seeing a bit of concrete
which is tattooed with pallets on it I
think it's very imaginative and very
good I must be I will support this thank
you thank you that Council bayford
thank you chairs this is really
difficult one for me because
um
I do think it looks old
and I do think it's probably crammed to
something some extent but other
applications have gone through that I've
considered to be be crammed to
um
it is providing a home for somebody so
it's it's taking up a space that's not
particularly slightly at the moment
so
very hard but I think in probably I'll
probably now in favor thank you
thank you thank you Council speaker
Council Robin yeah thank you chair I
could go along with uh councilor Hart
and uh you know I just think uh if you
look in London for those of us who go go
to London and the gherkin and what
they're next to or their historic
buildings modern and old they all go
together that's all part of a growing
Conservation Area in it so um it's not
only to maintain a conservation area if
they do something with it as well so I'm
happy to support that application thank
you chip thank you Council Auburn cuts a
wing uh I mean I think we need to view
some of these areas in in a in a motion
of moving forward these are
heagledy-piggledy areas we have in some
of our coastal areas that have you know
probably 50 or 100 years ago there was
another building appearing that was
slightly out of keeping with what was
there already and all we're doing I
think is repeating what's happened in
the past adding something that's a bit
different and a bit new I do think it's
sad that the the Flint wall will be lost
but I it will be hidden because I think
we need to think about introducing uh
new Flint walls that that then become
part of a new a new a new set of
Heritage moving forward and they are a
significant feature but in our in our
area here so that'd be my only objection
is that the the Flint wall is hidden and
lost and there wasn't a way of building
a new Flint wall which would have been a
new heritage
feature for future Generations
I think that councilor Winger
name's gone
okay
um I agree with it that it is a good you
it is a good use of space but I am
surprised our colleagues over there with
the green party haven't haven't noted
the use of the group The the one of the
one of the new new ideas that's coming
forward from Southern water the green
Rose thank you
how could I forget your name cancer
right
sorry about that thank you Council Ghana
yeah thank you I would just like to to
say that I'm I'm really pleased that our
presence in the room has enabled some of
our colleagues to look at these
applications in a much more
environmentally friendly way and I hope
that continues there's no
thank you thank you
righto members um
I can't see any hands uh erase so I'm
going to put this to you
to defer and Delegate for approval those
in favor
those against
abstentions
that has been carried thank you members
and myself
thank you members
that concludes a public speaking but
before I go into that I'm gonna have to
ask
counselor Wing to have a walk around
Margate for a few minutes put your coat
on
I think members are aware
one of the applications on here is
Council of wing so thank you councilor
wing and a happy Christmas
that concludes public speaking for this
meeting I will now ask the clerk to read
out those applications
for member wishes to reserve any would
they please
put their hand up or shout out whatever
you like to do to us thank you
Stephen thank you chair
the applications are a05 53 Addington
Street Ramsgate
a07 69 Westfield Road Margate
808 1 to 13 Church Fields Margate
a09 5A Royal Crescent St Augustine's
Road Ramsgate
A10 also 5A Royal Crescent St
Augustine's Road Ramsgate
a11 Depot Jackie Baker's recreational
ground
Highfield Road Ramsgate
thank you Stephen I haven't seen any
hands raised
so can I have a proposal to move that
the applications that have not been
reserved be termed determined in
accordance with the officer's
recommendation recommendations
second date
all agree
thank you members that concludes the
meeting tonight and I think before we go
I'd love to offer you all a drink but
there's no pubs open in Margate
oh on serious side
um a very happy Christmas to you all and
officers and look forward to seeing you
in the new year
um have a good one
thank you
it's like here